I think I'm just going to be like an Ethan Klein orbiter. Dan
himself has said this to me months ago that I think I'm just
going to end up being an Ethan Klein orbiter. Absolutely. Dan
has jumped ship. He is going to Ethan Klein. He is done with
Destiny. He's moving over to Ethan Klein. We analyzed how bummed
Willie Mack looks. No, you could do that. Yes, he does look like
He does look like his life's over. >> Hello. Nice to uh
speak with you again. >> I have a question.
>> Like two or three years. >> Do you like the Miami
police? >> Yeah, I guess. Yeah. You had an interaction
white people privilege >> way he lives his principles.
I'm pretty sure Connor would hold down a child for
We're pausing on Hassan. We're going back to the Destiny bot
here. Okay. He has just found out that Willie Mack has put the
dagger in his back. All right, let's see how he reacts. This
is silence after hearing. >> You can actually >> Oh,
no. Right here.
Right at the end of this silence. I think right at the end of
this silence, right? He says the Willie Mack bit. >> Could
have hurt to find another job. Why mean she's already >> Maybe
not. He had just figured out who the Willie M was from again.
Okay. Uh so he had Why did I say that? He had just been told
that William Mack dropped the video saying that he had sent child
>> crashed out as being a public defender and so now she's
like trying to raise money on that whatever website online. >> Oh,
he's talking about Lauren de Laguna.
I see. Okay, hold on. Let me pull up his uh schedule for today
or whatever so I can make sure I don't if he's actually going
to go and read the Maxwell testimony stuff. I don't see that.
>> Max Jesus.
Holy [__]
>> It's kind of an interesting raw drop. Okay, I would
send that clip doxing you to every employer she'll ever have
in the future. I just the problem is that like I don't know if
people in the real world care about stuff like that as much.
Like it's hard to
even understand.
Like I don't think people understand sometimes how like if you're
talking to a boomer and you're like here's a YouTube video of
this person talking on a thing where
they're talking about a guy and then they're talking about where
he lives and I don't know if a boomer would even necessarily
know why that's a bad thing. Like I don't know if doxing is a
thing at the forefront of everybody's mind or whatever. Is this
it? Was this where he ends talking about this? By the way, just
so I know for like uh is this roughly where Oh, no. It's not.
Not quite. Keep going for a little bit. But I think this is close
to where he just stops talking about all the stuff. So, Destiny,
in effect, broadly speaking, have the Snarkers one uh you sound
super doomer. Uh I'm not that doomer. I just keep on streaming
and
like 6 months from now,
generally they fall off. You just got to wait through it. But
I figure it's probably like the last big meme thing that can
leak from all the ro is my guess. I guess.
Ah, there it is. The last big thing, the last big bit of news.
I Isn't that insane? Just on its face. He literally he literally
just had Willy Mack publish a video saying that he had CP on
his computer and that Willie Mack reported him to the police
and he goes, "Well, I think this is like the last big thing that
could happen here, guys." I'm just going to go ahead and guess
that no. I don't think Willy Mack's video is the last big thing
that's going to happen. I don't think the Rose 17-year-old leak
or revelation is the last thing that's going to happen. That
seems like probably not. I'm just hard to say for sure, but pro
probably not.
Who knows? Maybe next we'll find out she was mentally maybe that'll
come out. I don't know.
Um, yeah, there was one other thing I was going to talk about
with regards to
but I don't remember what it was. Willie is literally throwing
you under the bus. It's I mean, it's not surprising. Like I said,
there's a ton of pressure on that guy visited my thread and there's
like a ton of people doxing and harassing and like calling into
streams and like crazy writing on everything.
Is that why he did it? Did he like just make something up? Or
if Willie just made something up because he's scared of getting
doxed, then why not just point out where he's
Seems like Willie just took the logs he had and went, "This seems
really concerning. I'm calling the cops." Where's the Where's
the lie? Just call it the lie. But it is what it is. Why does
Jessica hate you exactly? What did you do to him? My guess is
it has something to do with me and Cherry.
Um I didn't know until a couple months ago or a month ago. >> Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
a creative writing incoming. >> However long it was that
Cherry and Jessica were like hardcore obsessed in love with each
other since like the beginning of this year. I had >> Is
that a lie?
>> Is that a lie? >> You're not in love with me?
>> Since the beginning of this year.
>> So if he said now he would be lying.
>> Yeah. Okay. All right. No idea. So I don't know how
much that affects her or not cuz I mean like there's seem to
not care that much about all the pixie.
She's laughing at me as she walks away. By the way, you guys
can't see that cuz I don't cam up. All right. She's laughing
at me >> stuff. But then once the Cherry stuff got involved,
then he started to have much different feelings about it. So
yeah, I have no idea. >> Yes. When I found out you took
the person who I streamed with for a year and recorded them non-consentually.
Yes, that upset me.
Shocking. I know. Shocking.
Shocking revelations. person I streamed with eight hours a day
for at least six days a week for like six to nine months. Yep.
Yep. You said you were going to talk about the H3 threads. Oh,
the
Yeah. Okay. Have we I'm trying Have I moved on from all of this?
Uh you're talking about your position moving forward after the
suit. Are we getting a manifesto ever? Uh, if I were a manifesto,
it would just be like summarizing a lot of the lawsuit stuff,
but the um
the all of the peripheral skits, I I don't know. There's a lot
of random to go through. Yeah. I don't like I don't even know
if it's worth
I don't even know if it's worth going through all of it because
you to put together some Listen, the J6 video has to come out
first. Okay. Um, when it comes to the good one, does the drama
feel different with your personal family getting involved online
with it? Uh, yeah. Yeah, I mean it's more annoying, but yeah,
like I said, like people like like I'm pretty sure I watched
I don't know who this was. I think I was watching the food shops
person. Okay. >> All of the things that they fantasized
about Joe Biden doing to conservatives, Trump is literally doing
to sometimes other conservatives like John Bolton, >> I
thought they were all the same though.
Fantasized about it was now he's making it sound like there was
a difference. >> Is he Oh, no. He's talking about yesterday
or the day before. >> I see. Oh,
apparently uh this is one of the first days in a while where
Desty's experienced, you know, loss of
1,000 subs. We're starting to work backwards again, guys. Not
great. Not great. We covered the dance stuff. Yes, guys. We covered
the dance stuff.
>> Maybe it was the day before. >> Oh, oops. >> Alexa
to find it. But like Hassan was just like straight reading down
my
was straight reading down my Kiwi Farms thread. So, yeah. I don't
know. Okay. the um
oh because I was tying this to H3 stuff for the for the for the
H3 Hassan stuff there has to be a um there has to be a an understanding
about the related to the unilateral disarmament thing right so
on the other side like every single behavior has basically become
permissible and then on our side even if you call things out
honestly people will still try to
he's just trying to flip this right he's trying to he won't accept
his connection to Dan and the tactics that Dan used to go after
Han and he will not he will not accept that as being a part of
his thing if you want to apply his lens right you have to apply
Dan's like totally insane campaign against Twitch and Assan right
where he would bend anything in the most in the most favorable
way for himself possible you have to include that in Destiny's
actions as well
right and he doesn't do that he goes I dude remember when Pisco
started talking about Dan and Destiny goes Pisco Pisco I'm not
Dan I can't control Dan, right? But then he when he's talking
about other people, he thinks, "Oh, we all control each other
somehow. There's like a hierarchy here. There's some connections.
There's some collaboration going." It doesn't make any sense,
right? He won't take responsibility for his co-host, his business
partner, his best friend, his longtime streaming partner, right?
The guy has been on his stream longer than basically anybody
who's still there, right?
He won't take responsibility for that, but he wants me to take
responsibility for like bad empanada and Kiwi Farms.
Why?
how
optics you So for instance um and I still stand by my comments
like I said that like the stuff that Hosan is saying given that
people are being given that there are like threats being posted
every single day against you and everything else like that is
an unhinged that is a crazy crazy thing for Hassan to say the
fact that he can say stuff like that and worse cuz I I would
argue that stuff in the past has been worse and still get like
relentlessly
and just like unequivocally defended by not only his community
but everybody in his face. And then on our side, we're constantly
looking for like where are the optics points or like what are
like how how is Hassan going to escape if something happens.
I think that if you do that framing, I think you are always going
to lose. I think you're always going to be in a spot because
the there's like two things going on. One, because I see a lot of
people saying this, which is no offense, you guys are delusional.
People are saying things having principles does leave you in
a spot. That is foundationally what having principles does. Having
principles means making decisions that are not in your interest,
right, to maintain the principle. That is what having a principle
is.
Hey, I, you know, I could make so much more in profit with my
company if I just employed children, but I don't want to do that
cuz it's like dangerous and kids might get hurt. Yes, that is
like having a principle, right? Assuming that, wasn't it just
against the law? It is now. It wasn't before, right? They're
like having a principal is taking actions that would be beneficial
to you and is assuing them because you don't you think they're
morally wrong to do. Yes, by definition you are yourself. That
is what being principled is. It's whatever. No, shut up. Like
if Destiny would have made this one comment be cooked. No, he
wouldn't. Hassan said way worse stuff than this and he's had
about zero repercussions for anything. Right. Like again he's
openly watching terrorist videos on stream. There was some [__]
Israeli documentary that got released with [__] Nick
Palm sitting there watching a terrorist uh uh documentary or
not even that just the guy's like capturing the [__]
boat. That's just so unhinged. Um you got to sound like that's
not worse than than just saying this guy should be killed. You
you kill this guy. It's not worse than it's not worse than the
stochastic terrorism you do. I'm sorry. It's not. You could maybe
argue that like any No, it's not. It's not. It's not. It's not.
It's not. There's no ignorance to what Destiny does, right? There
could be ignorance to what Hzan does. Like Hzan could be ignorant
of, you know, how people might take that. There there's like
elements there where where he has a worldview that like there's
some there's some possibility that he's doing good. There's none
of that for Destiny. Destiny just knows that he's like calling
for unhinged violence against people. Um, by the way, none of
that is to say the things Han does there are good. Obviously,
I called him out for watching the Galaxy leader get captured,
watching those people get taken hostage and laughing about it
with Nick Poll, right?
I I have a ton of condemnation for that. But I don't have to
pretend that that's the same as Desi saying Hassan could be killed
for this.
Like openly saying things like the on October 7th were fake,
that half the people were killed by Israel. Um that just like
unhinged comment after unhinged comment after unhinged comment.
And when people like, "Oh my god, this is the one time Assam
was about to be held accountable." He wasn't. There's no there
is no accountability for this guy. Um I think at this point,
I think you kind of have to those comments aren't against like
platform to by and large. By and large, a lot of those comments
don't know TTS is not broken. Alerts are off right now. Alerts
are off right now. Alerts are muted right now. You're not breaking
my concentration with alerts right now. Sorry guys. Love you
guys, but alerts currently off. All right. Unhinged comment after
unhinged comment after unhinged combat. And when people like,
"Oh my god, this one time was about." He wasn't. There's no there
is no accountability for this guy. Um, I think at this point
I think you kind of have to I think you kind of have to move
the conversation into like if they're going to engage in certain
types of rhetoric then I think that on our side I think it's
fair to call that out and I'm not going to say to mirror it exactly
but like basically and then if they get to a point to where they're
genuinely uncomfortable then that's a good thing cuz it's like
okay well it's time to start bringing this down because on Hassan's
side right now Hassan is under the impression and he's he's correct.
So Desi's presenting this is just mirroring, but he will web
everybody together on the other side and he will not take accountability
for the people close to him, right? That's where the double standard
is. So Hassan and Bad Pad are the same people. Um and also he'll
just lie about Hassan. Say Hassan directly call said he was a
valid military target. Say all of this, right? It's just a lie.
It's just like objectively a lie. Read DG chat on screen right
now.
Destiny, aren't you basically just doing Newsome tactics? Oh,
how about we kill him? Fire. Fight fire with fire. Yeah, sure,
sure, sure, sure, sure. Um, yeah. I mean, I realize his audience
is going to do this. Okay.
Anyway, I'm saying that he he's saying mirror, but he's going
to web together all of his critics as one thing and do anything
to them, do anything back to any one of those people that any
one of those other critics would do. Okay? So, anything bad empanada
does, Destiny can do to anybody who's vaguely associated in the
bad empanada sphere. Right. That's that's the rules he's playing
by. But when Pisco says, "Hey, I think I think Dan is he has
your blessing to go after me like this." And and Destiny goes,
"I have no control over Dan. I can't tell Dan to do anything.
I can't be held responsible for what Dan does."
It's that is the double standard. That's insane right now. I
have no idea how you justify this. I have no idea how anybody
takes it seriously, right? When is YouTube going to demonetize
this loser? Well, hopefully uh if he keeps calling for Assan
to get hopefully at some point you would you would think >> and
that Assan can basically do literally anything that he wants
on his end and he will always get away with it. And then on our
side you have to play by this not even like reasonable set of
rules. Like I think it's fair to call out when people are being
unhinged. Um and and say that like if you were if you're going
to be unhinged like this like people could literally be unhinging
against you. It's super justifiable. I think it's fair to call
that out. I think factually it's correct. I think it's good to
call out when people are literally wrong. Like if people are
lying about things or if people are incorrect about things. So
people start saying like, "Oh, like I think Hassan like he murdered
his mom, right?" And like that's the meme that you spread, then
that would be stupid, of course. But um if you are
um yeah, if you're constantly trying to I don't even know like
what the standards you're trying to hold yourself to are. Um
and then allowing Hassan to constantly victimize himself and
like we out of everything. I don't know. I just think that's
I think it's cringe. I don't think >> saying Hassan called
Ila valid military target was trying to get her killed is insane.
That's a lie. That's just a lie. >> Any point in doing
that, but yeah, but you didn't specify that. So, please be more
careful wording next time. No. >> No, I don't think so.
I think I think you guys need to be more careful with not taking
the bait and holding somebody accountable for the unhinged and
crazy that they're saying, right? Like if there was a if there
was a moment like
if you just back up and you think about if you would to ask somebody
who's like observed the totality of all the situation you like
wow why did destiny say that about Hassan
then the answer would never be well he literally just said this
thing out of nowhere and it was crazy. The answer would be, well,
there's been a relentless amount of real life harassment directed
at every single person who is adversarial to Assan that can include
going after people's children, family members, and every other
part of their real life. And Destiny openly like pushes the this
to happen, right? Destiny is the person who actively taunts that
thread and gets them to continue interacting with him, right?
Destiny is the person who doesn't take any of his own advice.
Destiny is the person who literally provided additional information
on Rose so that his Kiwi Farms thread could go after her. That
is what Destiny does, right? He can say, "Oh, these people go
after anybody adversarial or anybody on my side. They go after
all of these people, right? He can try to paint that picture
and say, "Oh, well, imagine if this was Assan." He's basically
giving a like an allegory to himself, right? So, he can he can
say all of this, but he is the person who does all of these things.
He is the reason that the Kiwi Heart Farms thread has become
so unhinged towards him. It's him. It's him explicitly interacting
with the people who are most likely to do this, right? It's him
taunting them directly or being taunted by them directly.
All of the other stuff exists. Like I do my content, I do the
content I want to do and if I happen to like watch a Hutch segment
and criticize him, the idea that Destiny could say it's my fault
that something happens to Hutch or someone else in that thread
that goes down. That's
it's totally baffling to me. It's like it's absolutely to do
with you trying to drive a wedge between Hutch and the rest of
that podcast. That was what caused that. It's Destiny's actions.
And he will try to paint this as like everybody else against
him is doing this. It's not. It never has been. And and
you will find nothing
that Quimman Hassan bada I none of us have ever done anything
approaching putting out those pictures of Rose and taunting the
Kiwi Farms thread. That's crazy. It's crazy that he can accuse
anybody else of doing this given the things he's done. Son, while
people are getting killed in the United States for being has
continued to praise and worship terrorists and advocate for terrorist
propaganda and name drop people in the context of talking about
how it's permissible to kill people and then in that context
dese made this statement. I think that's meaningfully different
than just like wow this is just a random un thing out of nowhere.
That's what I'm saying. Okay. Yeah, this is dumb. Hold if Yeah,
I think you have >> Okay, here's a question. >> Shut
up. You have to do that or you've lost because you will never
ever ever win the um you're never going to win the battle of
trying to make sure every single thing that you say aderes to
some arbitrary rule set while the other side is allowed to act
with to operate with literal impunity uh in every conceivable
way. I think he's literally foaming at the mouth saying guys
just openly out here like I can't have principles guys to save
America I can't have principles for destiny to save America you
have to forgive him and totally absolve him of a 17-year-old.
Okay,
he's trying to save America, but he just has these shackles that
won't let him minor. Okay, if you could take these shackles off,
he could save America.
just help him break these shackles. Okay, and he will save America
for you.
Here's the VOD you were looking for. If he's going to continue
sending photos and video >> Oh, yeah. He's like literally
just reading down my
Kiwi Farms thread. Um,
>> this is something that was posted in Destiny's Kiwi
Farms thread, but he's reading an Alex Skmo tweet thread,
>> right? I think we all recognize that this is Twitter.
Yes, we all recognize that this is Twitter. >> Straight
reading post from my >> good friend Blab on Kiwi Farms
>> watching videos from Stale, who by the way, I completely
have under my control. I completely control the entire LSO subreddit.
That's why there was a false post about me multiple miners up
yesterday until I got the 2,000 comment. I don't know if it ever
got taken down or not. I saw somebody in chat ask about it. Maybe
it didn't ever get taken down, but supposedly I'm perfectly in
control of this subreddit. But I like how it sounds just doing
fullon like personal hit pieces now.
how in the world can Destiny Dude, it's so crazy. How many times
have we watched Destiny pause in the middle of actual like he's
like doing Israel research content and he gets linked like one
mic from PA clip and he's like let's run the whole mic from PA
gambit gamut again. Let's do all of the anti-mic from PA clips
all in a row. It's just so unhinged that Hassan would do like
two hours of like just talking [__] about me. Brother,
that's again what are you are you actually just angry because
it's like copyright infringement. You're like this is my thing.
Don't steal my thing. Like, is that that's all you could actually
be upset about right now? Is they're just copying what you do?
>> Uh, talking about me, he's retweeted something about
my kid. Um, yeah. I don't know. I think it's unhinged. Are you
read about the call Willie Mack made to the police? Uh, nope.
I like I'm I do what I am supposed to. Destiny, the irony is
they're saying stale campaign for DJ of the year, but his son
is actually more aligned with the guy who actually won DJ of
the year. Yeah, but I didn't campaign. I didn't make like a video.
I didn't even tell people to vote. I don't I don't think I even
told people to vote. Honestly,
even back then, I knew that was bad optics for me. I was like,
"No, you guys don't. You guys do whatever you want." Okay, you
guys do whatever you want. I'm not totally Even Even back then,
I knew. >> Advice by two different law firms. Like, I'm
I'm
remaining within my obligations for everything legally. So, on
all my civil case stuff. >> Really? Hold on. He's staying
within his obligations legally by leaking pictures of CSAM by
like leaking by like details from these
from CSAM. That's within his legal advice. That's crazy. Andy
B is going off. Okay. Andy B is going off book on this one. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. If you got to find that M that former minor, if you
got to find that girl who was 17 when you texted her. Yeah. Just
send send the videos. Yeah. Oh, wait. Not hold on. We don't know
her age. Okay. Here's what you do. You take that CC Sam. You
take of it and you send it to a group chat with 10 people. That's
what you do. Okay, that's it. Apparently, this is Andy B's advice.
Wild. Andy, how could you do this to him? Andrew Breler, how
could you do this to Destiny? Do the [__] research
stream. You
maybe >> we're silent. We're silent. We're chilling. Why
doesn't he just pull up the Willy Mac video? Could Can anybody
say why he wouldn't just pull up the Willy Mac video and say
this is Dude, it's totally That's the look. You know it's over.
Zoom in. >> Yeah. I think that's all I have for now.
>> Wow. Wow. Been getting told about this Willy Mack video
for 20 minutes now. So, you're wondering how I ended up in this
>> What?
I I might watch this Willie video later off stream. The
>> thing is like made so many crazy
random claims about me >> that but it's also just like
I don't want to go through every random
>> crazy random claims. Uh they're direct logs. He's basically
just like, "Look at these logs. Here are my logs with Destiny.
I'm reporting to the cops because of these logs." It's not a
crazy random claim. It's literally, "Look at these logs. These
are pretty. I'm I'm calling the cops." Every random thing to
talk about a particular thing cuz it's kind of gross and weird.
The um one comment that I made was the that Rose person early
on sent me a her iCloud or whatever with her and her boyfriend
saying that her and >> so he already knows what's in the
video. as possible. He's just watching it off stream or going
through his DMs with Willie like at this exact moment and figuring
out how he can like how he can save any of this, right? And he's
like, "Oh, they're kind of suggesting that I have 60 gigs of
I know I can show that I didn't have 60 gigs of her boyfriend
had recorded like 60 gigabytes of videos between her, him, and
like other dudes. I don't have 60 gigabytes of her on my computer."
Some people are trying to say that I have. So again, I don't
know why, see when he tries to he finds anything that's like
slightly off and he'll just he'll he'll jump onto that like it's
a life raft when he called out Kelly Gene for this. He was just
projecting, right? Oh, you were slightly wrong on something.
I'm getting on that. I'm holding on to it for dear life. Okay,
it wasn't 60 gigabytes. I don't have 60 gigabytes of child. It's
significantly less than that. I know I shared it with people,
but you guys lied about the 60. Okay, of all of this. I don't
have this. I don't know. That would be an ungodly amount of stuff
to to transfer. But u I don't have this. This is not on my computer.
This is they sent me from their computer. But you should start
suing all these people once the fixation is finished. Again,
the problem with suing people is that one, a lot of people don't
have money, so it's not worth it. Two,
um
it's just a lot of um
this that's just like a lot of paperwork, effort, time, stupid.
Three, I'm totally coping right now and none of these people
are lying about me. Unfortunately, I am the monster that they
say I am. Yes. Like three, there are no lies here. They aren't
lying at all. So I have nothing to sue them for. But I'm going
to keep saying it could be defamation without making any Dude,
what how do these people forgive this? What is their major complaint
about Cherry every time she's brought up? I don't see a police
reporting yet. I don't see a police reporting yet. I don't see
a police report yet. How about this guy stops fake me too people
and file a lawsuit if you're going to complain about defamation,
you loser. Okay. How in the world does this keep happening?
Can someone explain this? Why is he doing this fake me too where
he says people are lying about him and he doesn't file a single
lawsuit? Shut the up about defamation if you're not willing to
file a lawsuit. Loser.
Okay. You can't simultaneously say, "Well, I don't see a police
report from Cherry yet." And and also never file anything of
your own
by your own standard. You are a fake a fake victim. Which, by
the
by the way, that's not my standard. That's his standard. Okay,
that's the standard he presented. And it's a standard all of
his fans follow to harass people I care about. But they can't
apply that standard to him because then he looks like the biggest
[__] on planet Earth. And then um three, for defamation
of a public figure, you have to prove actual malice. Meaning
that like depending on what somebody seen, they might think I'm
a they like it's not technically defamation for them to do it
if I'm a public figure. Yeah. Is >> is there a lot of things
they could have seen that would make them fairly certain of that
fact or >> So is this just the same drama just rehashed
or what's going Yeah, it's just it's literally the same from
the >> Nope. It's totally different because Destiny exposed
this person's info and then they found out who she was. >> Same
rose person. Yeah. >> I just find it so funny that he consistently
consistently raised up Willy Mack as somebody they could trust.
Willy. Willy Mack. Willy Willy. And Willy's like, "Uh, wait,
are you telling me you have childborn on your computer right
now? You're sending me a of it?" Well, yeah, kind of. Uh, I gotta
go. I gotta go make a video right now. You to pull an H3 and
bait these losers. Why? And pre-register my [__]
with the Library of Congress.
Yeah, I'll get right on that. >> Hassan knew the lab stuff
of finding Hassan 17-year-old didn't make a I think you might
have a real death per se case against Hassan for spreading that
kiwi farms. Yeah, but I don't think Hassan was with Paris when
she was 17. No, wasn't that the whole point of that?
That's what I thought that I saw. >> Uh-oh. They found
a ticket of her but can't find her actual age.
>> My so if
so the thing is like this is all speculation so like I can't
unfortunately I just have no information about cuz I don't have
contact with this person. Um
uh reminder another lie. He told Pixie that he had been on the
phone with this person. He had multiple phone calls with this
person that they were a very close friend. Okay that's what he
told Pixie when he thought he could sweep this all under the
rug. He totally lied to Pixie. was like, "This is a very close
friend." Just so you know, I thought I could trust him with anything.
>> If the um Wait, what was I just about to say?
My my >> Oh, actually, Cyberdrifter, fantastic point. I
forgot about this one. Very important point. Oh, why can't you
contact this person? How'd they get that t-shirt? They pay for
that t-shirt. Couldn't you find them? Couldn't you find contact
info for them if you went to your shipping info for all of your
merch? Isn't that the point of selling merch is you get like
emails of people to resell, to re advertise to? Isn't that like
a massive thing?
Shouldn't you have a bunch of her info by virtue of having her
merch? Shouldn't this have been the easiest person in the world
for you to find?
Cuz there's one of two options. Either she paid, right? And then
her information would come to some vendor that you're using,
or
you sent it, in which case, what are we doing here? How the do
you not are you not able to find this person? >> I can
just swipe. I don't remember what I was going to say. Um, they
found a ticket for her, but can't find her. reaching out with
that information would be a huge violation of trust. And that
that that is the one thing Destiny cannot stomach doing, violating
people's trust. Actual info age. Oh. Um I think that the my running
theory, but I I mean I don't know 100%. My running theory is
that the solo dude is her current boyfriend or ex-boyfriend and
he didn't really want to be found. So before he leaked anything,
he wiped all of her um and tried to clear her social medias.
That's my guess, which is why it was so hard to find anything
of hers. But I can't know that 100%. That's just my
my
>> I saw this.
>> Okay. Um,
is this still going to be him doing stuff here? Uh, he's still
kind of
>> We'll see if he goes back talking stuff >> The
only thing these people want is attention. You should honestly
just keep looking forward and sees all contact. Let them scream
into the void forever. >> Um, yeah. I like I I feel like
I've said this a million times. Um,
I can do that and that's easy enough for me to do, but when the
people are all coordinating in like little discords and keep
trying to, you know, like with other people, whether it's Willie
or Connor or anything else, um, I don't like Connor because of
the things he said and how he's like presented his principles
and then totally totally lost them. Totally like thrown them
away the second it's more convenient to stick by you. I don't
like Connor for that reason. There's no coordination on that.
I don't like Connor for doing that. Okay.
Nobody's going after Connor. I don't know what this This is crazy.
This this framing of like people going after Connor when Connor
is openly telling his chat, "No, I I want to talk to these people
and I think I'm correct and and they can come on and argue."
There's nothing like at some point. Yeah.
Honestly, you should watch the Mac video. He's literally saying
you have 60 gigs of CP in your computer. Man, like I said, I've
already addressed this. Like this chick sent me um
uh screen. Uh, again, I think the real problem, Destiny, is that
you have CP on your computer. The size of that, how much of that
is up for debate. I don't care. I don't care if it's 60. I don't
care if it's six. I don't care if it's just the one video. I
think probably you were sent some videos by this minor and that's
a problem. You decided after hearing that they were a minor to
not go to the cops,
right? Isn't that the obvious moral decision? Oh, this guy's
saying she's a minor. Well, I should take these videos to the
cops. I think that's the obvious moral decision immediately.
No, I don't think deleting it is the right play. I think you
have to go to the cops. I don't think deleting it and letting
this person continue to be trafficked if that's what he thinks
is happening. If that's what his real concern is, oh, this person
might be getting trafficked, right? Oh, I need to save this just
in case it turns into something. No, you need to make sure actions
taken. But he doesn't have morals. He only has self-preservation.
He only cares about himself. So, what he actually did was he
was like, "Okay, well, in case they find out she's a a minor,
I'm going to hold on to this, right? Cuz there might be a police
investigation. And if she's not a minor, then I'm okay. But if
there if she is, I'm going to like keep the body here. I'm going
to keep the evidence here." You know, that cuz then it would
be trafficking.
Wasn't that a concern before you knew for sure?
Seems like it would be of a folder that she said that her and
her ex of stuff they' made. But I I mean, I don't have this on
my computer. I don't even think I told Willie I have this on
my computer. So, I have no idea why he's I don't know if Willie
posted any of our DMs, but my message to Willie was um she told
me she was 19 and she was in college and we were chatting. If
she was actually 17, people should be asking why that solo guy
had recorded like 60 GB of with her plus all the other guys she
recorded stuff with. Um and then I'm pretty sure even Solo said
that she lied about her age to me in that QB form thread somewhere.
I think all of Solo's original posts were deleted. I'm not sure,
but yeah, I don't I don't have this on my computer. By the way,
all of the conditional language, all of the like soft language,
I think. I'm not sure. I don't know. I don't know about this.
He know he can know all of this, right? That's the problem here
is he can say for sure. He can say for 100%. Because according
to him, he saved everything. He can go look up these logs. He
has no reason not to be certain of the things he's saying. Right?
The only reason to be uncertain right now is because you are
lying.
You're saying, "I think this is the case." You could know it's
the case. If you knew it was the case, you would say it's the
case. >> He has DMs in his video. He does his best to make
it look insane. Oh boy. >> So, I think he's just trying
to find this of the her sending the cloud thing with 60 GB or
something. And the logs. So, there are logs eventually that he
produces that say like, oh, if somebody ever looks at my boyfriend's
cloud storage, they're going to find a church or something like
that, right? >> I think that's what he's looking for right
now. Give me two seconds. Oh, this Jastaster guy is the big DJer
right here. He's the guy who's like he's the simile guy if you
don't remember him from the other night. Very funny stuff. I
didn't know he's a DJ the other night, but now I do know. So
she's magically a minor now.
Uh what? No, she's a minor because she's in the government database
as a minor at that time. She was a minor cuz she was in the government
database with the birth date that made her a minor with the that
Destiny posted a Willy. That's that's why she would be a minor.
Wow. Wow.
Hold on. I need to pull this back because I got to do a costume
change. Hold on. We got to do costume change. Costume change.
Costume change. Pulling this back a little bit so you can listen
to this guy in silence for a second. >> He has in his video.
He does his best to make it look insane. Oh boy.
We're back. >> You saying this you sent him is you confirming
that you had a video of her on your computer. There there's like
there's evidence that I have to collect and maintain uh on my
computer for my conversations with one my New York law firm and
two with my obligations I have related to my Pixie case. like
there are things that I have to have preserved uh related to
both of these court cases. I mean, I can't just dump a ton of
[__]
especially when I have no idea. I just feel like again, you don't
need a New York law firm to report
the apparent seam to the cops and ask the cops, hey, could I
uh could I like leave this stuff with you so I'm not in possession
of it? That's all that's all you got to do, >> Yeah, especially
when I have every reason to believe this person is 19 anyway.
Oh,
>> you don't have every reason. You didn't have every reason
to believe that. Especially not after Solo said she was under
18.
What are you saying? You did not have every reason to believe
that. Why you retained this? Solo said this back in
What do you mean you had every reason to believe it? No, you
didn't, brother. >> He said if you have the size, you should
>> It's just a screenshot that she sent me of the folder.
I mean, I can post the screenshot of what she told me. So, here's
the thing. If the of the of the video, now this doesn't excate
him, but one thing Desessie could do to to at least help him
with regards to the Willie video is he could show that the he
sent Willie is actually something sent to him by Rose that he
doesn't have that he didn't take that himself, right? Cuz what
it looks like to me is Destiny open had this open in VLC or had
this picture of it open in VLC and he took his own screen of
the title. Am I crazy? That's what it looks like to me. Let me
go Willie Max show.
That's what to me that's the concerning thing. It's not the It's
not saying that he had 60 gigabytes or something. It's this right
here that he says this is CSAM
and here's a VC screen of it. Who sent this VC if all the artifacts
of this stuff that he's sharing with Willie are things he got
from Rose, right? I would not call this CSAM even if the video
might be CSAM.
But I would say uh I would say if you knew it was Cam, you had
the video that was CSM, you reopened that to send a thing to
people. Yeah, you're you're you're sending details of the cam
to other people. Dude,
what are you doing? So now I I think this is the actual concerning
thing he sent to Willie. It's not the 60 gigabytes. It's this
right here. Okay.
Does he have a does he have his log showing that Rose sent him
this or he offered to fly her out the day after that video's
date? No.
that's funny. August 15th. It's almost like reporting to law
enforcement is supposed to make the situation avoid avoidable.
Yes, he was informed that she was underage. Okay. He was informed
she was underage. And instead of taking this to law enforcement,
he goes, "I think you're lying. I think you're bluffing. I'm
going to send this C Sam to a bunch of my friends so we can find
this girl."
That was the decision he appears to have made. Him assuming Solo
was bluffing that she was underage was a major blunder. If you've
engaged someone and their age gets called into question, he should
have immediately reported them to Discord and contact a criminal
attorney ASAP. The upside of maybe Solo was lying that she is
underage will never await her actually being underage. Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
You I don't understand how you justify going, I think you're
bluffing right now. Like that's actually thinking you're the
anime protagonist. I think you're bluffing about this person
being underage. I'm actually going to I'm actually going to just
like send of this material to everybody I know, you know? I'm
actually going to I'm going to go ahead and do something totally
different than what you should do in this situation. I'm not
going to go to the cops. No. No.
You can't control me. You can't make me go to the cops with this.
Well, he asked if he stole the video and he didn't deny it or
say that it was just a Yeah, I understand Black Irish. I'm saying
that if if this is a from Rose, that would go a long way to saying,
"Oh, I don't have that video on my computer." But that's he's
he's skating on the thing that he knows he has the size of the
the cloud drive, right?
And he is not answering like what the actual concerning thing
is, which is apparently you just took a picture of some some
some Cam and sent it to Willie Mac. He literally used the Sweat
City emote. He unfortunately did. Yes.
Sweatsy, why are you asking?
Sweat City, why do you ask? Oh, it's one of these here. In any
case,
I'm uh we're back. We're back in here. Apparently, this I don't
understand how. Okay, I don't know how. I don't see how or why,
but apparently this might get like actually worse in some way.
I
do not remotely understand how or why. Are we sure this person
is even real? Like, is she a catfish or is it a Lauren de Lagona
trying to get
um I'm pretty sure this person is real. >> Destiny, is
this just Lauren de Laguna trying to get you again? Destiny,
we know Lauren de Laguna makes fake accounts. Is this not just
Lauren de Laguna trying to get you again, buddy? At this point,
who the knows? Yeah, I still I technically still don't even know
if this person is like if this person was underage. This is like
an >> We'll cover the We'll cover the Ethan video in just
a second, guys. I got you. Like, if this person was underage,
this is like an insane This is just an insane
Hold on. If someone ever hacks mine and my boyfriend's cloud
storage, they will find a treasure trove. I swear I have 310
folders of photo sets. Total size 61.15
gigabytes. That's wild to me. But I hey I mean if
but no these are this is on their
uh cloud iCloud or whatever the this is.
Why is he showing this? Because in his mind be very vivic by
showing that he doesn't so he thinks Willie he didn't watch the
video. He thinks Willie accused him of having 60 GB of child
on his computer. Now I think Willie did say that but he's like
oh there's an accusation I can actually refute. So he's going
to refute that right. He's going to refute that and he's not
going to go to the actual tangible allegations, the actual like
devastating ones, which are things like, okay, why did why did
you send Willie a screen of one of these videos,
especially
given that the date of the video, the date in the title of the
video
indicates very obviously that she's a minor in the video. Demand
retraction will play back. Uh, maybe I'll watch it.
He claimed the DM you sent him was of a gab on your computer.
No, wait. What? No. Hold. By the way, it's a 4-minute video.
Oh, here we go. Ready set zurg. Unfortunate. Ready said zurg.
Unlucky. It's a 4 minute. It's 4 minutes. Destiny. There's literally
no reason to avoid this video, right? It's a 4minute video. It's
four minutes. It's not taking you out of your way. It's not even
Bro, it's a 4minute video. Did he get banned? Oh, I don't know
if that guy got banned. No. >> What? Did he show that?
No, you didn't send him that.
>> Go watch the video. >> There's I there's I'd never
that says this. I wouldn't even be able to send. I don't have
I don't have this. But okay, brother.
Brother, stop stop wasting our time. Destiny, just watch the
video. It's a 4-minute video, Destiny. Just watch the video.
Stop engaging with what your chat is saying about the video and
just watch the video. Just watch the video, bro. Just watch the
video.
Desessie, you need to respond to this video. It's literally insane.
He completely throws you under to the bus and says you have CP
shows a different
Oh, actually very violet's there right now. Destiny isn't in
his tweets. It's only in the video or JTO's most recent tweet.
Oh.
Oh, just watch a video, bro. Just watch the video. The VLC screen
recording Destiny. Oh, well, hold on. There's a bunch of stuff
here. You should get it. He's using these DMs as evidence. Oh,
yeah. Because I have of Yeah, we tried to do identification for
some of these videos. Uh, so we we tried to do identification.
Oh boy. Oh boy. So he did take So here's the thing.
That email gets more and more credible every single time.
brother, if you're one of the people who participate in
like we we
tried to do investigations into some of these videos.
So this would be after by the way and we see when those original
rose are from right we see we see sorry the pictures of Rose
that he used to taunt KF those were sent in December early December
purportedly when he started this group he already had significant
reason to doubt that she was 18 plus when they engaged
and he decided to take screen of
and send that to the group chat and he is admitting that openly
in this stream. I How is that not game set match? How is it not
over? How is it not over? Also, just to be clear, there's a good
There's a good
This is maybe the final lesson the internet will ever need in
Hey, it's shut the up Friday today, guys. It is. Let's not forget
it is literally Friday, August 22nd, and today would have been
a great day for it to be shut the [__] up Friday.
if you are a Destiny fan or Destiny himself.
Thankfully for us, Destiny is 200 IQ and he sees way past all
of us and he decided he was going to go on the fly respond to
all of this stuff and just confirm that like a group chat existed
where he actually shared a bunch of this these things
apparently. Brh.
>> Um and I tried to find her through her. >> Let's
uh let's try this again. I I have to listen to it again of Yeah,
we tried to do identification for some of these videos.
Um, and I tried to >> He tries to slide that in there like
it's just not a big deal. We tried to do identification for some
of these videos. I need to know who we are now. I hope that the
I hope the cops ask somebody. Okay. I hope I hope whoever Will
Matt called I hope those people ask somebody. Who's we? Who the
is we? Am I Is it crazy to have like names that I would want
in that group chat? Is that Is that crazy? No. No. No. No. No.
Be very vic. No. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. I'm
not saying I'm not saying names. No. Not Not the name Be very
vic said. Okay.
I I was more just thinking anybody who was like uh supporting
doxing. Like if all those people could be in that group chat,
I would I would think that was, you know, ironic. I think that
would be funny to find her through her boyfriend as well cuz
I have of when she would record stuff she literally has um a
lot of these were done via Skype calls with her boyfriend which
I didn't really figure at the time but we tried to find out who
the boyfriend was based on initials and stuff from here. Oh,
so you're the most you're the person with the most information
on the boyfriend and you're confirming that for all of us after
you said you had no information yesterday on Twitter. You could
possibly go to the cops. No, Tony school. Tonyy's school. Don't
don't talk Tony right now.
Stop. Stop. Uh,
dude, this is Let's just >> He is openly admitting to sending
this when when he had reason to believe significantly more reason
to believe that she was underage than ever before. He sent of
the she had recorded to this group chat and then they had all
they had enough information to apparently try to investigate
who the boyfriend was too. And now he is attempting to virtue
no one say why is nobody looking for the boyfriend? Cuz you hoarded
all the evidence. That's why nobody's looking for the boyfriend.
They're complicit. No, I mean, I don't know what the law is there.
I feel like that is totally being an accessory. Yeah, I feel
like that's totally being an accessory to this morally. Um,
it's hard to say without knowing what was sent.
I feel like
if there's if morally, if that's if they're not accessories morally,
if they're not like sort of um complicit morally, it would be
because of some like cult dynamic narrative, right? Like not
even narrative, like it would be because of cult dynamics. like
they're just literally brainwashed. So, >> but this is
not the 60 GB
CP folder or >> Oh, I'm I'm glad I just pointed out that
this is the actual problem. And he just confirms that that is
his video, that he did take that and that he did send that to
the group chat. I'll be I'll be real with you guys, okay? I thought
I was so smart when I was like, Willie needs to show us the ID
on this link because that ID on the link, if he if he goes copy
link here, it might have been pasted from the group chat. And
if that matched up with the group chat ID from the former from
the other Rose pictures, then we know that that's all being put
in the same group chat. We know that that's probably a group
trying to find Rose. I thought it was so smart. And Destiny just
walks out here and admits this openly on his stream. I don't
know. Is he trying to these people over who tried to support
him? Cuz it seems like he's got something going on there where
he has to cut the legs out of anybody supporting him. Is he like,
"Oh, these guys join this group chat. All these guy. I need everybody
to know that you're going to get in trouble with me. Okay, you're
all going down with me. I I like I I guess Okay, this is the
best I can do for what he's attempting here. Okay, 20 streamers.
Yeah, this is the best idea I can I can think of. Okay, he knows
that it's going to be proven that he did this, right? That he
did send this stuff to this group chat. He knows that that's
leaking. He knows it won't stay hidden for much longer. Okay,
he knows all of this and he's trying to soften the blow for his
community when this is all proven by admitting to it now. He
knows that, oh, the the obstac's gone. This is going to get leaked.
I'm going to get in like trouble for this. But for the community
to try to keep this streaming community going, I'm going to talk
about it now. Like, this was obviously the thing to do. I That's
the best I can do for like some rationale here. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Welcome, guys. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Destiny caught with a
17 minutes ago.
Oh
no.
Oh no.
Guys,
it might be over. >> Oh no.
>> It might be over for this guy. All right. It might be
over. We've got the Ethan video. The thumbnail is actually what
you guys need to see first. Okay. The the thumbnail. Let me Let
me go grab the thumbnail from somewhere.
YouTube
grabber. Give me the Give me this thumbnail. Give me this thumbnail.
Oh, dude. It's over.
It's This is great stuff. This is great stuff.
Destiny, I think you need to take some time off. Okay. You need
to take some time off. I'm just going to Hold on. I I feel like
we might need to Hold on.
What do I need? Don't worry. Don't worry about it. We'll uh Sorry.
This thumbnail is just making me too happy. Okay. This is a future
DK/Shut thumbnail.
Yeah. I think most people don't put this word in the thumbnail
because I think it can get the video demonetized,
but uh it see it appears to be over. It appears it appears to
be over.
Not totally sure. Oh boy. I think we've I think we only have
minutes left here for him to keep admitting to crimes and so
by the way, I think we've already got this, but somebody we all
always be archiving. Okay, always be archiving. You got to archive
this stream. Somebody needs to be archiving this stream. The
stream needs to be archived in its exact state. Okay. Needs to
be archived. Now, Dan was already doing this behind the scenes.
Uh I'm going to leak a little thing here. Um I was told that
Dan was doing this because he had approached a certain big commentary
YouTuber behind the scenes and said, "Hey, the Destiny stuff's
getting kind of hot. I think I'm just going to be like an Ethan
Klein orbiter." Dan himself has said this to me months ago that
I think I'm just going to end up being an Ethan Klein orbiter.
Absolutely. Dan has jumped ship. He is going to Ethan Klein.
He is done with Destiny. He's moving over to Ethan Klein. No
more No more Destiny. We're in Ethan Klein orbiter now. All right.
Yeah, 100%.
100%. >> So, the entire video is based on a false I don't
know. I'll watch it after stream while I get it. >> 4 minutes,
dude. 4 minutes. If it's if it's all built on a lie, it's 4 minutes
>> Do you use pim? What is py? How about people who feel
you were negligent in verifying your age and feel you probably
should have been in other encounters with girls that might be
underage? I don't know how to respond to that. I mean like you
can argue that I mean nowadays I have no problem checking an
ID cuz if somebody feels um the problem is like even check because
the problem is like people have fake IDs so even that's not um
doesn't really tell you 100%. I don't know if there is like a
100% way to verify a person's age. I feel like context clues
are usually your uh hold on hold on hold on context clues uh
Destiny don't go to the context clues. Dessie. Destiny, no. Destiny,
do not go to the context clues. The context clues do not help.
Oh, I'm getting my braces off today. Yeah, I want to fly to Miami,
but my parents are really strict. They don't let me do stuff
like that. Do not go to the context clues. Destiny, do not do
not do not.
Best bet there. So, like for instance, if they're on only fans
or they do something like that, I figure, okay, well, they there's
somebody doing some kind of ID verification here for Tinder.
Yeah, you didn't. You explicitly didn't have this. You explicitly
didn't have
You explicitly did not have this. >> At least my recollection
is Tinder >> No, not at least my recollection. You can
just know this. You can just Google it. There's no reason to
lie about this.
It's so unfortunate that Willie Mack enabled spreading of this
lie that Tinder did age verification. It's very unfortunate.
We don't like that. Not >> And age verification and she
used Tinder a ton. Plus, it's selling stuff online and everything.
Okay, this is almost certainly plus his
>> selling stuff online on non-ageverified
Only on non-ageverified platforms with other people and everything.
So unless like every single person she's meeting like has no
idea what her age is, including classmates that she supposedly
recorded videos of. Um, passports only. Oh, true. Actually, are
you going to report it to the FBI? Uh maybe the when I was doing
work with the New York law firm, the goal was initially cuz the
packet that we put together was um a thing that we were I think
I I don't remember if I said the original packet was going to
the DOJ. That was the goal of that originally because I thought
that the the stuff that the solo guy Why why did you pause it?
Why wouldn't you just if the work was done, you paid for this
work, why not continue paying for it? even if the girl isn't
underage was um criminal in behavior. One trillion% that was
criminal behavior. Um and then I also said that they could lean
on the potentially the trafficking of this trigger or whatever
angle as well. Although she's a minor that's like a million%
even more true. >> Wait, what
did he acknowledge that she might have been a minor to the New
York law firm? So he wasn't thinking, oh, she's obviously 18.
Um, but that was the the goal initially was just was to send
it all to the to the DOJ and then have them try to pursue it
there. The at the end of the day for all of this stuff. Um, like
I'm not worried about the criminal stuff, which is the PR is
obviously annoying, but
why wouldn't you be worried about the criminal stuff?
Uh, what why would you not be worried about the criminal stuff
at all?
That seems wild to me. Imagine a world where Buro just wiped
his the moment JTO reported the leak in December. Wait, I didn't
What do you mean reported the leak? I didn't What? Oh, I see
what you're saying. Uh, when I talked to him in November about
it originally, when I talked to him about the Lauren Southern
leak, by the way, I didn't know there were nudes there when I
told him about the Lauren Southern leak. There were no nudes
um present. It was just the Lauren Southern DMs were the things
getting leaked back then. Um, I didn't know about any nudes until
he told me that he'd sent that person videos of him sucking
and then he didn't say anything else. So
yeah, might have been real different if you just cleared everything.
I only care about PR is a weird thing to say. That is him trying
to maintain the strong front. I think that uh he's broken no
laws. Not true. What do your lawyers think of what's going on
with the weird procedural the other side? Um I mean basically
there's all just delay tactics or stalling stuff. Do you know
her actual name? The name of the video and the name on the tickets
don't match. I don't I still don't have contact with her or the
guy. I don't so I'm not even sure 100% if the if the information
or anything is true. Yeah. >> Wait. So Willie Mack internet
warriored himself into reporting CP that was already being prepared
for the FBI. No. Destiny himself has said that he was no longer
doing this because Pixie was mean and people on the internet
were mean. So he was just not he just canceled his New York law
firm
because Pixie was mean and people on Discord are mean. So no,
he was he wasn't really preparing it for the FBI at all. He uh
he totally stopped. It wasn't being actively worked on. It's
so funny that these people can't see the actual problem that
he was sending screen caps of CSM to a group chat to find a try
to find the girl.
They don't see that that's obviously the issue here. >> People
are baiting. Be wary. True.
You just got to You just got Oh, catfish. My >> Hold on.
By the way, I don't I don't Maybe I shouldn't say it. Hold on.
No, no, no. I want to see the cooking style guy. That guy's in
here. When you date 30-year-olds, you don't need to ask for ID
to age verify. Yes, Kogan style. This is true. That guy's in
our chat fairly often, too. Destiny, the Willy Mack videos. The
Willy Mac is career destroying. You got to respond. He literally
says you have CP calls. Uh CP calls the cops in the vid. It's
literally the biggest throw under the bus.
Destiny, you have to debate him. Debate him now. >> People
are baiting. Be wary. True.
You just got to You just got >> Oh, dude. Do you guys remember
MVTT was like uh he was like a mod here. He was like massive
in this chat for a long time, right? Don't worry, I'm sure the
other commentary dooders will on Willy's investigative journalism
abilities again. Uh actually, I kind of do have criticisms for
that video. Absolutely I do. I'm trying to hold them back cuz
like obviously the Willie video is going to set off a cascade
of people like kind of walking away from Destiny. Like
the outcome of the video is good. I'm sure Willie he did his
best. Okay. or something. I don't know. Whatever. Who's left
to walk away? Not soite. And Connor. Connor. Not soite. By the
way, yo who I'm still not going to ask to walk away.
Wes, by the way, that's it. Right. Wes has never Wes basically
said from the beginning, yeah, I wouldn't be shocked if he wanted
to [__] Miner. Yeah. Wes was like on board with everything
Destiny could have possibly done. Wes was like, "Yeah, I don't
think that I don't even think that's bad. Like, I don't even
care.
Wes is not violating his principles to stay by destiny. I don't
need Wes to like go away from him. Right. Tom Fer's right now.
Wait, what? Hold on. Here's the thing. People are getting like
mad about Oh, you shouldn't have kept I I don't care. Like the
the evidence of the the CSAM shouldn't be deleted out of hand,
right?
It shouldn't just be deleted and you pretend you didn't receive
it. That's probably what to do just in case there's ever a trail
built that shows that it was sent to you, right? The only thing
you can do when you have CSAM or potential CSAM sent to you is
report it to the cops.
That's your only option,
right?
In my opinion. Like you could have an obligation obligation to
not destroy evidence, but I think that obligation just goes to
like, yeah, you should take that to the cops.
No, I don't know why you have to retain it. I don't know why
you have to hold on to it. I don't know what rule there is about
that. Lawyer first. They'll advise you on what to do. Sure.
notes on Discord. They have all the records to pull and they
are likely mandatory reporters, so he can delete it. Oh, like
if he reports it to Discord and says, "Hey, I I was sent this
uh he could just probably get in contact with somebody and figure
out that like, okay, you guys are going to report this to the
FBI or whoever you have to." I see. Yeah. The the concept that
like he had no choice but to retain this is just insane, right?
I don't believe that he necessarily has to delete it the second
he finds out she's a minor, right? I do think that like, hey,
he can report it to Discord. He could go to the cops. There are
like multiple routes he could
And the biggest one is you definitely don't have to start a 10person
group chat to try to find the girl you are concerned might be
a minor
and sends from those videos to that group chat. Probably I don't
think Andy B was on board with that. All right. He seems to say
that like, oh, I only acted in the way my lawyers told me to.
I'm guessing Andy B did not say go make a group chat and share
this stuff. I don't think so. I don't think so. Oh, catfish.
My bad on banana. A lot of people think it doesn't make sense
that someone over 18 who'sish wouldn't have an only fans. So,
you should have known, but a ton of woman would have been in
self mode. Well, there's a lot of people just sell not safe for
work stuff on Twitter, too, cuz the thing is for only fans, it
doesn't um if you don't have a pre-existing platform, only fans
doesn't help you market at all. Or at least it didn't back then.
I don't know if they do now. So, there are people that sell not
safe for work stuff on Twitter. And
and and
that was a brand new account. It wasn't it. I think we So I I
understand the in the Twitter DMs it says one day old account
but I thought there was independent verification that it was
a like April made account
like it was made on April 1st or April. I thought it was like
basically confirmed that the account was like brand new right
then. That doesn't explain selling on Twitter and not Only Fans.
I would say the reason you'd sell on only fans is just to go
through the age verification process so that you can say here's
my only fans as well,
right? Like it's a platform set up for it.
He is saying Willie and Ethan are virtue signaling in his DG
chat. Well, apparently he goes through and reacts to Ethan right
now. So, apparently he's going to go react to Ethan. Uh I don't
know. Did this video premiere? This video must have premiered,
right?
Apparently, they live reacted to it. Anyway, okay. We are Okay,
we need to finish this up. We can finish this up. I think he's
just about done talking about this. Go back to this. We We finish
this. We do the Ethan video and then we'll see what else we got.
We've got some Connor stuff. We'll see what else we've got for
the night. There's lots of content. What's up? Watching you back.
The walls are closing in on Lil Stevie. The walls are closing
in. Like for real. Like not in a cope way way. The walls are
closing in. Um not to not not that any of that means that his
audience will take like a significant hit, right? The audience
is a cult. The audience that core audience of like probably 4
to 8,000 viewers, those people are a cult. They won't leave over
this. Okay.
But you know what? You know what prevent you know what hurts
the stream way more than like cult members leaving.
No way. I don't think you're I don't think you're telling the
truth. I don't think you're telling the truth. I don't think
you're telling the truth. Yeah, you're lying. O kind of crazy
how Oliver and everything is just out there in the public yet
hasn't come out to talk about it publicly. Seems sus. Yeah, it
could be. Or if they I mean it's probably something. If they
have a ordinary real life now and they don't want to tank their
own real life, they probably don't give a
or not. They don't give a [__] but they would rather
be as far away from it as >> What is she supposed to like
take her like Instagram with her college friends on it and say
like, "Hey, uh, the fact that this guy messaged me and me when
I was a minor has come to light. She's supposed to make a statement
to like her closest friends and family members. Where is she
making a statement? Where is that happening?"
Bizarre, bizarre comment. Why'd you post her public college and
DG chat? That was very
person was and I was able to find the person. What? But it doesn't.
>> Dude, dude,
this was this was the I Trust me, I'm psyched he did this stream.
Okay, I'm psyched. This is maybe the worst idea to stream this
response ever.
Why did you said Why did you say her college in DG chat? Oh,
cuz I wanted Kiwi Farms to find her, guys. I just wanted someone
to find her. Why'd you post her public college in DGG chat? That
was very reckless. Cuz I wanted somebody to find her cuz I have
no idea who the [__] this person was and I was able
to find the person. But then there's another stupid thing too
because people are like, "Oh, like Destiny was praying on her
cuz he knew she was underage." Well, why the would I post the
picture or whatever? Yeah, I This is This is such insane cope.
This is like be If I thought she was underage, why would I post
that picture, brother? If you didn't know, I just want to make
it clear that he is actually saying like pretty much verbatim.
He's not given any evidence. He's not given any reason that he
thought she was above 18. Really was like, "This guy would be
totally
if he didn't have like pretty near bulletproof evidence that
she was 18."
Seen clips from the Ethan video. Holy [__] is brutal.
Okay, well, we'll go to
dude. Yeah, I get I get why he's saying this a little bit, though.
Like, why would I do this? That would be crazy. Yeah. What's
What evidence did you have that she was 18? She said she was
18. When I said she was 19, she didn't correct me. What are we
supposed to do? She's selling online. How did that not mean she
was 18?
Yeah, she was off of all the verified platforms, age verified
platforms, and yeah, she was getting her prices off. And yeah,
her parents were really strict and they wouldn't let her fly
anywhere. But like,
she didn't correct me when I said she was 19. I wasn't able to
find the person because also the theory a long time too was um
that I like I was pursuing underage people. I knew this person
was underage. I was trying to hide it from everybody or something,
but I was just never able to find the person. And again, I have
no reason to think she's underage. Um, I still don't even know
100% of that's the case or not, but I mean, if it was, not only
did she
Okay, this incinerated kid guy kids guy. This is this is the
most cope. Weaponize your enemy's autism. God destiny.
Imagine reacting to this guy who's been so out about Kiwi Farms
doxing people and harassing people and he explicitly gets baited
by them into leaking additional information so that they can
dox the underage girl he was. Okay. And your response to this
information is, "Godson, weaponize your enemy's autism." That's
cultlike on a level that uh nobody else in the internet approaches.
Okay, that's crazy. She lied to me though. Solude said that he
lied as well. So Jesus, what do you think about drama of the
year for the DJ 2025 awards? Good question.
I'm just looking for any actual push back here. Is there anybody
like
this? Wait, did you get KF to track her down? Did you get Kibby
forms to track her down? Well, I know anything I post in DG chat
ends up on Kibby forms because they'll read my so I figured they'd
find her from there. But no, you explicitly said you were taunting.
Like you explicitly invoked them. You were explicitly taunting
them.
Explicitly
saying Kiwi farmers can't investigate anything. Kiwi farmers
are [__] Here's like even more pictures of her. Go
ahead. Not go nuts, Kiwi farmers. Did you see the extreme dad
message? No.
Why? What's What's the extreme dad message? or if she was underage,
why wouldn't Solo come out and say that originally? Well, that
was kind of my thought. And funnily enough, I think just to go
believed uh the exact same thing. Um I think I posted those DMs
because Solo Wait, which one? Hold on. >> Well, that was
kind of my thought and funnily enough, I think believed uh the
exact same thing. Oh, yeah. I've said this every single time
I brought up that conversation that I thought Solo was trying
to hide that uh was like knew her in real life because he was
trying to hide her identity. Yeah, I've said that every single
time. No, extreme dad. No, shut up, extreme dad. No, just pay
me my $500 when you owe it you. Um I think I posted those DMs
because Solo originally said, "Oh, by the way, when you started
talking to this girl, uh she was underage, so be careful." But
Jessica and me both figured he's only saying that because he
doesn't want me to try to track down. >> No, I consult
you and when you were unsure and I said I'm pretty sure he did
this in reaction to me basically finding a Twitter handle. I'm
pretty sure that's what happened. Right.
I conso this guy cuz I felt bad I I felt bad for him still that
he just had this whole Lawrence Southern thing leaked.
I I was so idiotic. I thought this guy was some kind of victim.
I was a total [__] Okay. I felt a little bit bad
for him and no, I didn't see that. So, I said, "Hey, I'm pretty
sure that he did this in reaction to me." Now, what I would never
have said is, "I'm pretty sure she's not a minor, but you know
what? Just just to show show how sure I am, I think it would
be wise for you to send of she sent you to a bunch of dudes.
I think you should do that." I would never have said that. Okay?
There's a difference between saying, "I'm pretty sure this is
what's happening." versus, hey,
go ahead and share around that seam.
They're very, very different things. Uh, yes, be very vivic.
Yes, absolutely deserve downfall. Yes. Down the girl so that
he can cover his own app. That was my assumption. Why is the
ticket not sealed if it's her juvie record? Yeah, maybe. Yeah,
I have no idea. But like if it is the case again if it is the
case that she's underage that solo dude is like federally fely
like ultra cuz that would be an insane amount of inducement and
creation of like underage that would be crazy. Did you have a
Tinder or rather did you connect with her there also for the
Twitter stuff she was selling at the time you spoke? Yeah, on
her on her Twitter profile, she had 18 plus written and she had
a Tinder already. So, but I mean
Oh, well, she she wrote 18. Dude, he's unironically doing the
Leon the professional thing. She wrote, "Guys, if she writes
18 plus in her profile, doesn't matter what she looks like. Doesn't
matter no matter how old she is, you have plausible deniability."
Now, let's go.
Hold on. Just quick quick update with respect to not watching
the Willie Mack video on stream. Okay. going and responding repeatedly
to criticisms from Willie Mack without engaging with the video
directly. What is the old Destiny's thoughts on this exact pattern
of behavior? >> And how does a fan know if a commentator
is lying or not? Fans who watch Hassan, for example, well, that's
there's a different level. Kassan doesn't do lies like that.
He does a thing that um he does a thing that's way more cringe.
Like there are there are heristics that you can apply to people
like him where it's like, oh, he never watches any of the original
material. He never watches or responds directly to criticisms
from people that criticize him. Right? These are heristics that
I think are broadly accepted and applicable. Yeah. >> Wow.
It's almost like you should engage with the material directly
and it's a 4-minute video and you're actually getting out of
this stream without watching the 4-minute video. Wow.
Crazy. Also, he's apparently getting out of this stream without
his his fans noticing that he admits to starting this group chat
where he shared the screen caps from those videos.
Brother,
you can fake an ID. You can Yeah. Set a DG bounty for us to find
him and the finder reward gets 30k. Yeah, I could do >> Sure.
Maybe 30k is a small price to pay. I I Or just take all the information
you have and go to the FBI and don't spend any money. Just go
to like the FBI. Go to any law enforcement agency.
Dude, the first time Destiny's ever said this in his entire life.
Yes.
Yes. Yes.
All right.
Continue on here. If the ticket was from after she was juvie,
it wouldn't be sealed. Well, the ticket says it was paid off
in 2021.
So, it would have been from when she was >> Apparently,
people have called this county
and they don't seal juvenile traffic tickets or something like
this.
I think uh Vigilant Stream is just saying this. Do >> you
have any reward for finding Soul's information? I'll give you
a free tier five sub if you can find it.
>> No way. No way.
No way. I'm just done talking about everything until the case
is over. There's literally zero reason to do it. Either bad faith
actors in the KF community will try to weaponize everything.
Or trying to virtue signal like Willie Mack and Ethan will just
try to demonstrate their virtue to people.
Bro, this guy's so cooked. This guy's so cooked, dude. He's so
cooked. I cannot. By the way, this is just him opting out of
responding to the Lily Mac video. He'd easily respond to the
Lily Mac video or the Ethan video or anything. He was just on
the whole page of, "Hey guys, I'm uh I'm gonna respond to everything
because you have to because if I don't then nobody will." And
now he's like, "Guys, now that there's like now that all this
evidence is out there, I'm uh I'm going back to hiding. I'm just
going to go back to hiding again, guys. I'm going to go back
to hiding. Can't respond. He has no defense."
Destiny is literally in the bunker in 1944. There are there's
absolutely a good um downfall meme that could be made. Okay.
Somebody's got to make the downfall meme. It will It will come
out eventually. All right.
Except, do you even have enough Do you even have enough generals
left to do the appropriate downfall meme? There was one when
the initial leaks dropped. Okay.
Is there are there even enough people left?
Is it like food shops? I don't even know if you can do Darius.
I don't I don't know. I don't know.
Uh it's like Darius, not soite. Connor food shops. Not even Darius.
Sorry. Nse. Connor food shops. That's what we got. Okay. Tom.
I don't know if we're going to have Tom for much longer, guys.
We learned just Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. I forgot that this
actually goes Hold on. Wait. We We look at this and then we uh
we once again Okay. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. This is not the
right clip. [__] Whatever. The the clip on not directly
engaging with your with your criticisms. Okay. Who's this? Solo
guy. Uh, Solo is the guy who leaked stuff. There's crashed out.
We covered it. Covered it. Covered it. >> Okay, we're almost
finished. How How badly is the universe telling you to just end
it when you go from Okay, you the first news story of the day
is people getting investigations from the FBI purportedly in
line with the Epstein investigations. Right. Isn't that what
the John Bolton stuff is about? Like that's the universe coming
for you, right? Right there. They're like, "Destiny, there's
only one Destiny. You're not getting out of this one. You're
not getting out of this one, buddy. There's no one to debate
anymore.
There's nobody to debate. FBI, open up. I think I think that's
the end, by the way, of the comments from the stream. I think
he now goes into uh
I think he he goes into some other stuff now.
All right, I think we're on to the Ethan Klein video. Oh, we
got the West. We got the West as well. Hold on. The West video
as well. We'll do Ethan Klein first. Okay. Destiny caught with
a 17-year-old. Quick 10-second meme. Oh, this has to be I hope
you understand the the rhythm of the stream right now. This has
to be hyper relevant. Don't [__] it up. Don't [__]
up. >> Stop it, y'all. Quit playing. Quit
>> I didn't do this stuff. This is not me. I'm fighting
for my life. >> You hit it. You You hit the right note.
Okay. You hit No, you hit the right note. You hit That's exactly
where we're at. That's exactly That is exactly it. Well done.
Well done.
I trusted and my trust was rewarded. Feels great. Feels great.
>> Uh, today I bring you a breaking story that was brought
to us from Friend of the Show Willie Mack. Um, he broke a story
here. He was talking to Destiny, uh, who's being alleged of with
a 17-year-old, including receiving,
uh, nude videos of her. Uh-oh. Is right. That's a what they call
dicey dicey or what Jared Fogle calls nice.
This is uh I believe this is Ethan and Dan calculating that they
just have to cut this guy off now entirely, right?
And this has to be up for Destiny on a personal level because
I'm guessing Dan knows about him that are like that is like insane.
And how much exactly Oh, XQC's watching the Willie video. Let's
go. Let's go.
How much exactly does Dan know about Destiny? And him and Ethan
are over here making a video on Destiny. Anyway, Willy's video
is really short. It's 4 minutes long. I'm going to watch it,
but I encourage you all to go show uh Willie some support because
pretty incredible uh stuff he's doing here. He reported him to
the police and I based on what I seen, I would not be surprised
if the police have questions for him. Let's take a watch. >> I
reported Destiny to the police. This is not clickbait and entirely
has to do with the DMs he sent me. A few days ago, a Reddit post
showed that the girl
is Everybody Everybody's just going to throw that up now. Everybody's
just throwing that up. Who gives a [__] It's so stupid.
Angulated it through like 20 face recognition ID and somehow
and matched up all their moles and was like, "This is the person."
It's nuts. Okay.
Ethan is uh he's explaining, okay, the actual autism that went
into this. He's explaining it directly.
Now, that wasn't
There's multiple people doing this at the same time. Okay? There's
multiple people doing it at the same time. All right? The guy
who did the face recognition thing was not the guy you guys are
thinking of, by the way. He just sent it to the guys you guys
are the guy you guys are thinking of. Anyway, you can't hide
anything from them. All you have to do is not uh with miners,
right? Or do anything miners and then you don't have to worry
that much about Kiwi Farms, right? But anyway, go ahead. uh Willie
>> what I usually do and reached out to get a comment.
He said the girl Rose told him she was 19 and in college at the
time and that the leaker Solo, who is her ex-boyfriend, confirmed
that she lied about her age to him. This is true. In similar
scandals, this is where people usually argue, is he lying? Did
he actually know the age? Is it his fault if he was catfish?
I usually >> he's forgetting somebody. Of course, Sin Jared,
my favorite, the original who who's continues to skate by totally
unscathed. Go ahead, Jared. Tell us this. I mean, he's give me
tell us >> what this all came down to was people saying
that I was exchanging nudes with fans on Snapchat and Tumblr.
>> Will you extend an olive branch to Willie Mack? Nope.
And I'll explain why at some point in the future,
not even remotely. >> And a lot of people want to know
if I did any of that. >> Well, you he didn't obviously,
right? So, good. >> Yeah, I did. >> Willie Mack objectively
swept and and put in his video despite saying otherwise in those
DMs that Oh, yeah. TW Tinder was an age verified platform actually.
Yeah, there's reason to believe that if she was on Tinder that
she was age verified.
She's a
No, we're not building a bridge there. There will never be a
bridge there. That guy's a loser. He sucks at his job. Just because
Destiny happened to be in a place where he was so rattled that
he started confessing to crimes. Doesn't make Willie a good investigator.
Doesn't make Willie a good YouTuber doesn't make him good at
research. Doesn't make him good at his job. Okay.
>> Wait, what? >> Wait, what? Yeah, that's a direct
excerpt from his video, but that's pro Jared. Go ahead, Willie.
>> All the details to come out before I comment. This is
not why I went to the police. It's because he continued to write.
I didn't know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording, blah
blah blah. And then he shows me his the top of a video clip and
says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls. That's
absolutely insane to >> Yayon. You have no idea what you're
talking about. And uh find another channel to watch. Bye. Think
about him doing all of this if she was 17. >> The irony
of that is absolutely unbelievable. I mean, bro, it's on your
>> You think that's crazy? Yeah, it is. It's on your computer.
>> I don't think the big bombshell here is the fact that
it's called screen >> No, you know, I think it's everything
>> Why? Why would he say this? But it gets >> On
Skype calls, that's absolutely insane to think about him doing
all of this if she was 17. Well, XQC swept, rolled his eyes at
it, and skipped the Willy Mack
Really?
That's uh
That's That's kind of wild, isn't it? That's
what How How did that even happen?
No
Said it was too complicated. A 4-minute
was too complicated. Okay. Well, this is insane to me because
he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP while sending me a of
the alleged CP. So, I asked to confirm if he just did that. If
you were sending me this, I'm guessing you still have that video.
Destiny replies, "Depends on why you're asking, but yes." >> Does
it? >> Now, the depends on why you're asking is interesting
because it implies that under the right conditions, he would
send this to him. >> Also, like the cheeky emoji like depends
why you're ask. I think what's actually going on there is
he's saying like depends on why you're asking like if you're
going to report me for saying I do have it. I think that's clearly
what he's saying. But >> do you want to see like >> that's
kind of was like >> I don't I
now at the risk of actually assuming that Destiny's not a total
[__] I don't think he was doing that with like I
don't think he was doing that saying do you want to see the video?
You want to see this like purported seat? I don't think he was
doing that.
I don't think
>> It depends. Do you want to beat off to >> Yeah.
It's like or or are you trying to get me busted? You're trying
to beat off. Then we're dogs. Let's go. Anyway, then he continues
to just say, "Yes, I have it." >> I created copies of all
of our messages and everything when that court case started.
Just to be clear, he's admitting to having alleged CP downloaded
on his computer. He literally has the video open as I'm talking
to him. I go, "Bro, there's been allegations at least since my
last video that she was underage and you still have potential
CP of her?" He replies, "I have an obligation to preserve relevant
evidence, etc. So, I created backups of all of the important/relevant
>> So, this is not true. You do not have any obligation
to save child
under no condition.
>> Legal or civil. >> Are you under any obligation
to save
on your hard drive >> to help? >> The concerning
thing to me is that he said that Andrew Breler apparently advised
him that this was the case. Like listen, I talked to my lawyer
or I guess whoever his New York law firm is, but it's I assume
Andy B and Andy B was like, "Hey, you need to keep this stuff,
okay? You need to keep all of that. >> Help defend yourself."
>> Wait, Tinder? It's not required age verification, Dracula.
There's There was not required age verification when Rose was
on Tinder. It is not a valid defense in any way. It is only being
said to obiscate. It did not have any required age verification
at the time that she was engaging on it. at the time that she
was DMing Destiny >> in court. >> Sir, I wouldn't.
It's voluntary. So, do we know she wasn't age verified? We're
talking about what Destiny could assume. It's not an age verified
requirement platform, right? So, there was no way that he could
know that she was age verified. If if it's not a requirement,
then how the could you say, "Well, since she was on Tinder, I
assume she was 18."
Are you What? Yeah, I guess answer that question. I'm going to
keep watching. >> I would like that evidence to speak for
itself.
I'm accused of having child the evidence the child.
>> As you can see, you are right, sir.
This is how child works. If you have it,
you're guilty. If you have it, that's a crime. The only people
that can legally have child,
anyone under 18.
Um, I really hope that's not the case because otherwise, if somebody
just puts child porn on your hard drive, you are
I sure hope there are other factors that go into this and Ethan's
not just totally pulling [__] out of his ass and
being a right now. Yeah, exactly. Evil Johnny Bravo. I think
to me, if you're not notifying an authority immediately, there
is no possible reason that you could retain this stuff. So, if
you can't ever know, how does anyone use that site for hooking
up? Uh, okay. There's a couple different reasons. One, there
are different laws for whether or not you can you have an age
of consent in like different states that would be below 18. So
you could totally somebody who's below 18. There are a lot of
states where you could be 19 and somebody's 17 and it's not illegal.
Okay. Obviously that would just be one, two, you could do your
own age verification off of Tinder cuz you're meeting them in
person. You could see their ID, right? It means nothing to be
engaging on Tinder at all and then say this person engaged on
Tinder who I've never met in real life, so now I know they're
18. That is the dumbest thing I've ever heard. It's the excuse
Desty's going with and you're saying it's to bring that up. No,
it's for him to bring that up and it's for you to defend it
>> is a an investigator, an official, a police person who's
in the service of uh investigating or evil crime, right? >> Um
that excludes Destiny, of course. >> Now,
I don't think he's that dumb. So, what my theory is, and again,
>> this is all conjecture, and it doesn't really matter,
honestly, but I think he kept it in the spank bank.
I think he just kept it to cuz he likes it.
>> it's just so stupid to keep it. >> Like there's
got to be a piece of your brain and I know Destiny is a very
sharp guy. I've seen his debates. I've seen his videos. There's
got to be a piece of your brain who's like, "Well, okay, so alleged,
Hold on, let me get this straight. He's just learned recently
after this Kiwi Farm thing happened a couple days ago that she's
17."
>> According to Willie M. No. He was told by Solo in November
that she was 17.
No. So, no. >> It was already like a potential though before
that. So, >> before he found out for sure, I guess. >> So,
a few days ago is when this story
>> and um so according to his account, he just found out
which I have I have some interesting info on that, but let's
>> Cuz I don't think I'm allowed to delete it. Lol. I don't
know if it counts as hiding/destroying evidence. >> That's
easy to find out. >> It's child. >> It's I mean it's
easy to find out. You ask your lawyer. >> It's actually
child.
>> Uh I don't know if I should erase this child. That's
a question he asked himself. Do I need to save this child for
evidence? Uh no. No, you don't. Pretty clear. >> Reply
talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me. Who keeps this sort
of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed
to or not? Isn't that something you want?
>> So, is Desty yet again sending nudes of a girl without
her consent? But this guy, but but this time it's a child into
Willie. No, he didn't send nudes. Uh, he sent screen caps from
a video he was saying was of her. Um, so I don't know why he
would say that if it wasn't true, but apparently he did.
TJ, I told you you should delete it. Uh, that's wrong. He is
just wrong. Um you if you are sent child by somebody the first
step is not delete. That is not the first step.
That is obviously not the first step. That is obviously not the
first step. >> That's a question he asked himself. Do I
need to save this child for evidence? No. No you don't. Pretty
clear. >> Reply talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me.
Who keeps this sort of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing
if they're supposed to or not. Isn't that something you want
to confirm? I continued. You just let me know you have CP videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still have them. Do you see how this is? So now
I've confirmed that this guy has child on his computer. Am I
8 years?
Why does he have CP? Why is he accessing that CP to send to people?
Why is he sending of that CP to so many people so
Why are these things happening? These are the questions. Not
why does he have it? Why does he have it is a question. It is
up. It is clearly in my mind indicative of the fact that he wanted
this to blow over, but if he got caught, he didn't want to also
have deleted the evidence. Okay, if let's say they go to Rose's
logs, let's say they find Rose or Solo and there's evidence of
them sending videos to Destiny and Destiny's deleted that evidence.
Well, he's [__] right? But I think his primary objective,
his primary, his number one option is hoping it all blows over.
That is already he's already guilty because of that.
>> Years of reaching out to people over allegations, I've
never had anyone admit that to me. The last message he sent me
was one. I don't even know 100% of her age was legitimately less
than 18 when these were taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure
if he has child. >> That's exactly where my problem begins.
If you don't know for sure, you should never engage. Like you
need to be more responsible than that. >> Yeah. And that's
the ProJared thing. It's like Pro Jared. He was getting nudes
from his fans and he goes, "You got to be 18 to send them." And
they're like, "Yeah, of course." And then he just collects everybody's
nudes. It's like that's why you don't get [__] dudes
from random people online, especially if you're a [__]
influencer,
right? And you know, she's hella young, which again, I have proof
of that, which you guys, I have something to show you guys at
the end that made Dan almost keel over. It's that insanely cringe.
You guys are going to die. So stay tuned to the end. It's gross.
100% of her age was legitimately less than 18 when these were
taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure if he has child on his
computer. >> It seems like he kind of was like, I don't
know if she was a minor or not, but now it seems like they know
she was a minor. And he continues, so it's like he was already
up keeping it, but he had some plausible deniability. But now
>> he didn't have plausible deniability.
He got told by the guy who produced it that she was a minor.
There was no plausible deniability to not have gone to any authority
there. There's zero. Now it seems like they know she's underage
and now he still has it for evidence. Uh judge, I would like
to plead uh my defense here. Um I kept the child on my hard drive
because I thought the police might need it >> for you,
judge. I kept it for you. >> Would you like to see it,
judge?
>> Yes. Yes. This is Okay, this is funny. And this is another
funny point, though. Like the white hat thing is hilarious. Okay,
listen guys. I just, you know, just in case this ever became
a case, I didn't delete it, guys. As you know, what if what if
what if it became a case? Should I have reported to the cops?
No. Pity is suing me. Why would I report it to the cops? Pixie
suing me. J's al-ging me. Why would I report it to the cops?
>> Why don't you post it on Twitter? uh Destiny. That way
everyone has the Well, don't do that, by the way. Obviously,
>> He's just 99% sure. Got it. Two, I'm pretty sure I have
an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case. I talked
about it with my lawyer already, specifically with regards to
the Rose stuff. So, >> yes, you have an obligation to save
stuff. There's spoil. You don't want to be spoilating evidence.
>> That does not include child.
That's like emails, text, data, convers. Not child
man, not nude images and videos of
Uh, Cyber, I believe he says he has logs of what he sent to Abby,
and he hasn't deleted those. He just hasn't produced evidence,
but I he would have to do the whole log dump, right? And I don't
even think I don't even think people believe him if he did the
whole log dump. They just say he probably deleted it, right?
But he I believe he said that he has the evidence of the Abby
logs. >> That is not part of the legal ca uh that is not
part of our legal system. The [__] is just mind-numbingly
dumb. >> He's just 99% sure.
>> Hold on. >> What the [__] >> Holy
[__] dude. What's the matter? What happened? What's
going on? >> There's so much porn. >> What the hell
are you doing looking at my private [__] >> What
are you talking about private [__] Johnny? It was
wide open. There were >> This is I You guys got to send
relevant stuff. Okay, if you're going to interrupt the video,
send relevant >> Got it. >> Two, I'm pretty sure
obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case. >> Okay,
it's funny. I've talked about it with my lawyer already, specifically
with regards to the Rose stuff. >> Did you tell your lawyer
you have n you have child? Did you tell your lawyer? Okay. Uh,
small asterisk. Yes, I'm supposed to save all my communications
with her. Small asterisk. Um, she's a she might be a minor and
I might have videos of her naked. Is that going to be a problem?
Do you think he said that to his lawyer? >> I don't because
in
>> his lawyer would have been like
>> I'm I don't know. What is is a lawyer has I don't know
what the lawyer I don't even know what you do at that point as
a >> You just I can't represent you. >> You go to
the cops and you say, "Hey, I think we we have possible seam
here. Here's the evidence." I think that's what you do. >> In
the message before to Willie, he sounded like, "I'm not sure
if I should be saving it." >> Oh, remember? Yeah, this
is a good point. Soapbox. This is a good point. Do you guys remember
what Destiny's response was when Pixie's lawyers subpoenaed two
years of his Discord logs? I'd rather kill myself than hand those
over. And I think we're all starting to see why that might be
the case. I'd rather kill myself than hand those over. Uh
we'll see. Okay, we'll see. One can one can hope that he's not
lying on that front. One can hope. >> There was hesitation
in the way he described it for a while. >> It does not
sound to me like that was an order from your lawyer to keep.
>> No, of course not. The no lawyer would tell you that.
You know why? Cuz it's illegal to have child
>> It's such a cult. Is Destiny's career going to recover
from this? I mean,
you know what? If if you think that
credible allegations of him spreading Seam to his fans, if you
if you think that that is the same as other stuff he's been accused
of in the past. Okay.
Not to not to say anything of the other stuff from the original
leaks in November that he still has to deal with. Do you think
any of this is the same? I don't know, man. I don't know what
to tell you. I don't know what to tell you. I don't think you're
seeing it correctly. I don't think you're seeing it correctly
at all. Is a Tom Foolery take. Is that what we got here? We got
Tom Foolery. Oh, that's probably not true. His lawyers probably
have copies of these things. His lawyers probably have copies
of it. It's already been submitted to the courts. So now the
courts have uh copies of it. the defense team or sorry the prosecutor
team the
sorry the plaintiff's team also has copies of these things. So
literally like like truly Pixie probably has copies of all of
this stuff now on her own computer. She probably has copies of
everything that Destiny's team has sent over. He they Pixie may
have even have copies of CP on her computer now as well. Like
>> dude, the
dude Auggie hit this so on the nose when he talked about it.
The DGR like the DG orbiter takes before the actual copus flow
in. Okay. Like this is just he's just saying totally totally
totally insane things right now. Oh yeah, I think they'd see
that this is like possible CP and then they just send it to Pixie.
Um yeah, it seems possible, guys. I think so. I think they do
that. Why wouldn't they just send somebody else to Pixie directly?
Why wouldn't they do that? >> There's probably tons of
people who are holding these records who all need to be able
to look through them for their own court cases. They all probably
currently have CP now. All of them. Like there's probably tons
of lawyers, tons of people involved in these cases who all currently
are likely holding CP.
Okay. Can we think of like a reason why we might not consider
lawyers, judges, cops holding this CP the same as random private
citizens holding it? Can we think of we Tom, I just want you
to think really hard right now. Okay, I know this is difficult.
Is there a reason that judges,
cops,
lawyers might be in possession of child in relation to some case
and that might not be the same as just Destiny possessing the
same child? You know, I can't think of anything. I think that's
all the I think that's important to put all those people in the
same group and to just say it's the same
W. Tom. We get some W toms in the chat. I didn't think of it
that way. And now that he's put it that way, I just realized
that like maybe it wasn't so bad. Yeah, like FBI investigators.
I bet the FBI investigators investigating Epstein saw a bunch
of child. Can we get those guys in prison? I think those guys
got to go to jail, right? You Tom, >> that's probably not.
>> Wow.
Amazing. Amazing.
Okay,
we're back to Ethan's video. >> So, he went from I don't
know if I could delete this to my lawyer says it's totally fine
to keep. I don't know the law, but the idea that his lawyer would
tell him to hold on to CP for a civil >> His lawyer, by
the way, is not going to like that. >> you're telling people
I told you to do what? I don't think the bar looks kindly on
on stuff like that. >> Doesn't seem likely to me. I don't
know. Law Tube can figure that out. Three, if something were
to come out of this, I don't know if I'd want to wipe everything
and not have something to turn over to the authorities. >> Not
child, right? Like, it's just simple. Like, I just go back to
this part, this thing here. It's really simple. You just say,
"Well, not child." If you have nudes, pictures, or videos of
of of children, then not that.
Everything but that, right? >> To wipe everything and not
have something to turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically
whenever a political creator is about to give a >> to be
clear, I agree that the lawyer wouldn't have said just hold on
to that stuff.
I agree with everybody that says that. I'm saying that you don't
just delete it before you like you you have there's another step.
There's another step that should happen here.
I bet Prince Andrew is an easier client to manage. Well, I I'm
pretty sure Prince Andrew didn't have a fetish for being punished.
Okay. The way Destiny does. That's got to be rough for any lawyer.
>> A hypothetical. You know, you're about to hear some
weird [__] I can see that. Evil Johnny Bravo, Destiny's
lawyer. By the end of this, Destiny's lawyer will be suing Destiny
for defamation. Yeah, I I I just did what my lawyer told me to
do. This Andrew Breler guy, he totally he totally told me not
to contact the cops. Or he just said, "Hold on to this child."
That's what Andy B said.
Andy Andy's not going to like that. >> If hypothetically
her boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her, getting
her to other dudes on video for him, and if there was ever some
kind of investigation into that, am I hurting the chance of looking
into him by deleting all insanely stupid. >> Oh, how noble
of you. >> This is just investigator destiny.
He likes to do that in his private time. He likes to help investigators.
>> I I It's so important that I hold on to this child
for the chance that one day, one day I'm given the noble opportunity
to help find the real perpetrator.
Right? That's my >> I'm glad that everybody's pointing
out how insane this logic is, right? that he like we can all
agree on this one, right? It's totally insane
to pretend that you can just hold on to this and not call the
cops and like oh you're being a good person by doing that is
>> My passion I want to stop ch I you have to keep to be
able to see his video with DG chat. I thought about doing that
pulling DG chat up along uh up alongside this. Give me a second
because there were DG chat logs where Destiny was getting upset
about this video. Give me a second. Let me let me let me check
it out. Let me check it out.
Uh
what is this? Lauo, this isn't even the same person. This is
a totally different woman from her bongerland who is visiting
family. Holy.
>> Got to watch it on mute. >> Oh, this is like a
different person. Okay. Okay. Uh that's at the end. Oh, Ethan's
going over his own. Well, we'll see what the response is at that
point. I don't even know what that [__] is. >> Pornography
just the tub. >> What don't you understand? >> Yes,
exactly. Naive American Psycho. Yes, if you if you spoke to a
lawyer, they'd say go to the cops or they'd say like
I I think there's the cops or Discord seem to be two routes you
could take, right? You receive that over Discord, you report
it to Discord, Discord has to go and report it to the >> He's
saving space. >> Native native. Sure. >> In his heart
and in his holding space in his heart. >> I got no space
in my heart for child porn. None. Empty. Total void there. This
message is so crazy. If hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever
was actually trafficking her and getting other dudes to her on
on video, is that the video he has? He's making it seem like
the video has of her having sex with somebody, which is even
I don't know if it's worse cuz it's all child, but that's really
graphic. Yeah. And if there was ever some kind of investigation,
am I hurting any chance of looking into it? Bro, you're participating
in it. If people are looking into this and trying to bust
uh uh people with child, you would be you're not you would be
the defendant.
He thinks he's the Dexter Morgan of >> right? He he surprise
[__] >> He views the child so he knows that
it
>> I He is great. He goes, I surf the web all day looking
for child.
As soon as I find it, I save it onto my hard drive. So that one
day,
one glorious day, when the police come looking for me, I'll be
able to hand them this drove of child to help them catch all
these criminals. Awesome. Wow.
>> Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the CP is because
of a hypothetical criminal case that he is not pursuing at all.
Okay, maybe these reasons are legally sound. If you cared about
doing that, you would just turn it over.
>> If you're like, there's a a crime happened here against
this girl, you would send that >> over to the FBI or something.
You wouldn't like keep it. I would like to know how many times
he's opened that,
>> bro.
Bro, you know what's the chances that that dude hasn't continued
to beat off to that? >> It's just not even Jesus
Christ. That's actually, you know, now that I think about it,
I that's probably accurate. I I'm sorry. Unfortunately, that's
just almost certainly accurate. >> Again, I don't know
for sure.
>> That's my opinion. >> He was just making sure
the fire wasn't corrupted, you know. >> But this is the
logic I use when people when I talk about Michael Jackson. We
know the kids slept in his bed. Lots of them. What's the chances
he didn't at least flick one of their dicks? Like, you know,
something happened. >> A fairly vulgar way to put it, >> right?
It is. Yeah. No, I'm with you. >> My point is is like he's
got it. >> Well, I heard that the kids said they were 18.
>> he say he actually filmed it just in
>> I saved all these I saved all the videos just saved
even some underwear just to have, you know, evidence.
>> Officer, I have all of these videos of me having sex
with these children just in case you needed it.
>> They said they were 18, officer.
Oh god.
>> That came from his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and just
saying anything to make it sound better to me. I don't know.
I'm not a lawyer. I just know this guy's admitting to having
CP in my DS. >> Listen, I'm not a lawyer. I just talked
to one on chat GPT
and Chat GBT told me there's no uh you can't you can't have >> So
over. How do you respond to these memes? I don't think you do.
I don't think you do at all.
>> Dude, it's it's over >> for any reason. 50 gigabytes
according to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he
doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong
somehow make Destiny in the right? It makes no sense. For all
he knows, her boyfriend could have been 17 as well. Dude, you
were 33. I reported this to the police and recorded my interactions
and calls with the detective. >> William, how you doing?
Okay. >> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great
question. >> You have uh screenshots or copies of the
>> of when you guys spoke about having teleport and all
that? >> Yep. I also sent him my DMs with Destiny. I don't
know if anything will >> Tom Fuller in full on defense
mode right now, biting some crazy bullets, saying it's not even
a red flag.
That's interesting.
You analyzed how bummed Willie Mack looks. No, you could do that.
Yes, he does look like he does look like his life's over. >> Hello.
Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great question. >> He
does look happy. Okay. He doesn't look happy.
>> When you guys spoke about being teleported and all that.
>> Yep. I also sent him my DMs with Destiny. I don't know
if anything will come from this. I don't like leaking DMs as
me respecting what creators want. >> Bro, bro, bro, it's
a crime. It's okay in this case. Like, and also, you teased it
out of him. Very straightforward.
You didn't like even trick him, >> You're like, "Do you
have child on your hard drive?" He's like, "Yeah, do you want
to see it?" >> The record allows me to talk to all sides
of the situation, builds trust with the creator, and also allows
me to get follow-up statements for when the drama develops. But
when you tell me that you're in possession of and going to remain
in possession of CP, that confidentiality is over. I shouldn't
even need to say that. If Destiny ends up being legally in the
right to keep it, then fair enough. If he ends up getting charged,
then I'm glad I did something. I'm just trying to do the right
thing in a situation I've never been in before. >> Yeah.
And you did the right thing. Honestly, that's pretty badass.
You called the police. That was absolutely warranted. And it
seems like they're seem pretty interested in uh I mean, they
got the messages. They know >> it's not even a theory anymore.
Destiny actually loves being humiliated. Why would he keep incriminating
himself over and over and over and over and over and over and
over and over again? No, that is the only explanation at this
point, right? And I think he loves humiliating other people,
right? That's why when when like Connor comes out and starts
defending him like I tell me that at least 10% of this isn't
the fact that Connor went so hard in the paint for him that he's
just like, "Oh, I can totally make Connor look insane right now."
>> Oh, you know, >> it has to be a part of it. That'd
be crazy if Destiny goes to jail. That'd be a twisty. You might
say it was his destiny. So anyway, okay. So if there's people
who are like, well, he thought she was 19.
Um, he didn't know she was young. Remember? So he was 33 at the
time. Um,
Max said, Willie Max said. So look at this. This is part of the
leaked conversations. Now, I'm going to warn you guys, this is
going to make you want to die,
but it is important. The first one is not going to want to make
you die. This one's just a little tease. Uh, so he's talking
with her. She said, um, got to watch it on mute. He sent her
a video. Got to watch it on mute. Family and kids all over the
place here in our house. He >> I believe that one is Rose.
>> Yes, ma'am. And then he said, hm. >> Oh, wait.
Maybe this one is Rose. >> If you can give me a discrete
>> I've never seen I've never really gone over these ones.
>> Get rid of your little feats. >> Well, he says
he says it's not Rose. Destiny apparently says it's not Rose.
The road stuff's already damning, right? This isn't even the
same [__] person. This is a totally different woman
from Bongerland. Hold on.
Where are we? Here. Right here. This isn't even the same person.
This is a totally different woman from Bongerland who's visiting
family. Holy
It's actually so cringe how all these random DMs get conflated
together.
Okay.
Let's keep watching. Okay.
just sit on
>> cuz that's nothing compared to what's
>> I uh I've never even covered these. I don't think
I'm not sure I've ever covered any piece of these. >> But
also, it's it's definitely doing a little uh age play here. Can
I see your little feets? A secret video of your >> Little
feet. >> Okay, you guys ready?
>> Oh, this is the first this is the first leak that talked
about him having a foot fetish. Okay.
>> All right. >> All right. Here it goes. She says
to him, "My parents are super super strict. Don't do this. Don't
do that. Don't go there. Don't talk to me." So she's she I mean,
when you're like, "Oh, my parents don't let me do anything fun."
It's like, "Oh, you're a kid." His response is this, and I will
read it verbatim.
He said, "Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. We did read
this part. I thought this part was from Rose. Damn it. Why did
it get linked this?" Okay. Uh, the parents thing does apply,
though. Not super strict, but the parents saying, "My parents
won't let me fly." That is an actual thing. That is an actual
thing. Her parents wouldn't let her fly to Miami.
That is actually from the Rose Logs. Says, "Hm, well, it would
be so hot to drive you home from a date and make you suck me
off in the car. I'd love to send you inside your parents' house
after making you swallow a full load from me." >> Oh, hold
on. Hold on. >> She was a child of life. It's I would say
this is this is still weird with like these DMs right here, right?
It's still very weird, but this is not Rose. >> That might
be the worst thing I've ever >> It's the worst thing I've
ever read. >> I'm a little desensitized cuz that's the
second time I've read it. The first time my jaw was on the floor,
>> but that might be the most up disgusting thing I've
ever read in my life. Also, why does he say I have a problem
with the way he says make you suck?
>> Yeah, I have a problem. >> Yeah. Then that follows
up him saying that he has been in orgies before, but not by free
will. >> Wait, what? >> Yeah. You see right there?
She says, "You've done group orgies before?" And he said, "Not
by free will." >> What? I missed that. Have you? Oh, have
you done group before? Y asked her, "Not by free will. I was
>> I believe she says that."
>> No, she's like, "I was" And he's like, "Send me pixel
your feet." >> Oh, she said that. Yeah. >> She's
basically insinuating that she's been raped or assaulted.
Hold on. Hi, Chy. I know. It's very concerning. It's very concerning.
>> Don't worry. We're This This man is going to go away.
>> He's Chief is a minor. Honestly, he's big, but he's
a minor. He >> I know. I know. I know. I know. He's going
to go away.
>> Cute dog.
>> I'm going to stick to the content. >> I'd like
to make the content. >> Dick, take a load and go into your
parents house.
>> Can you not? So yeah, I don't know, but it's safe to
>> I'll say that's a that that's like an oldtimer on its
own, right? >> Just say that. Um Oh, wait. Just real >> So
just like this this line, I'd love to send you inside to your
parents after making you swallow full load from me. That's like
an oldtimer like
and parents are super strict. Well, I'd like to send you over
to them with a load of my semen in your mouth. >> Yeah,
I don't know. But it's safe to say that um Oh, wait. There's
another one. I'm probably getting my braces off in a couple of
weeks.
>> Oh, exciting. Are you looking forward to
>> bro? You're talking to a child. You're 33 and you're
talking to someone who's like, I can't wait to get my braces
off.
>> What's next? She's going to be like, oh, I I sorry,
I have to go. I have to play go play wall ball >> with
my friends. Ow. Hi.
Hi. Hi. >> Sorry. Um, >> how old are you? >> I
I need to go >> wall ball. >> I don't know. That's
what I did when I was a kid. >> Handball. Same thing. >> No,
I played wall ball, but like fifth grade, not high school. >> Yeah,
fifth grade. >> Okay. Is wall ball a thing? >> It's
a kids thing at school.
>> I called it I think I called. Okay, fair >> We
called it wall ball. >> What's it called? The one where
you hit it in a circle. >> That's why handball. >> Oh
no, that's ball tether. >> Tether ball, bro. >> Tether
ball. Sorry, I got to go. Well, tether ball's kind of epic. >> We
should get one is fun. >> This reporting Willie M report
on this. I want to give a shout out to Willie Mack who did this
reporting. Willie Mack, go send him some love and support. I
don't know what this gonna be like for him. Uh or if people are
going to be mad. I don't know what's to be mad >> Uh Ry,
can you just link me a time stamp to XQC starting or are we doing
are we doing like the whole thing? I would just take a time stamp
to XQC watching it >> once you read this kind of a message
like that. >> I can't click through clips if he's still
live. If he's offline, then it's fine. fan
and you're like, "Listen, he thought she was an adult. >> He
didn't do anything wrong. She lied." Projared defense, what the
are you going to say about this? >> I'm genuinely curious.
I am so curious. >> Read DG cop logs. Are there more DG
cop logs after this? I think I have them up here somewhere. Hold
on.
Uh, it's not luck. It's all intentional from the other side.
IP ban Saron. Nope. What did Sarcon say? Let's set him off here.
See, earlier today, you mentioned a few times that you never
around with underage nudes, but if I recall correctly, wasn't
there an incident where Tonka Lamau was talking about you spreading
a 15-year-old when you were 22? Although, I think you said she
was wearing a bikini. G, but that's probably where this is headed
next. Shrugs.
Um, wait, you absolutely
I thought he absolutely shared that 15-year-olds and was like,
"Dude,
how did I say no? Isn't that just real? I thought that was real.
He's posting at IRC." Yeah. Okay. So he did spread a 15-year-old.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Just making sure that's not fake. So
banned him. Banned Sarcon for that. Said nope. Uh my hands are
super bound on all the current litigation. Everyone on the other
side. Dude, is this There's no way. Lexer Queen. There's no way.
She's saying, "Are you going to respond to this?" And he says,
"My hands are bound." There's no way, right? When he's been responding
and talking about this all of the time. Lexer.
God damn it. What did this person say?
do time stamps. Hold on.
This is 1855 24. We go 18
54. Destiny at Destiny. I am pissed about how little you care
about your image. Can you please say how
defending your honor?
Can you not hold on about how little you care about your image?
Can you please say how defending your honor is something that
can be balanced with a pros and cons list? I'm getting mad. All
these think they can say whatever they want and get away with
it. Please, my man, stand up a bit or at least open our hands
to be a bit more proactive.
What? Bro, what is he trying to be? What are they going to be
more proactive
What's What's going to be more proactive here? I'm very lost.
I'm very confused. Huh? What? I might leave I also might leave
the XQC reaction until tomorrow. I think I might I might divert
over to Merc stuff after this. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
We'll do maybe I think Okay, apparently Ry says there's nothing
else. Hold on. allegations. I've never had anyone admit that
to me. >> No, no, no. Oh, copy or something. Dude, you
understand the meta data be behind uh evidence and information
on your on your computer. >> If if that's the original
file, you would want to keep it as is for for for court or for
whatever the Am I right or wrong about this? >> Uh you're
definitely wrong about this. You definitely don't have to keep
the metadata. Like
deleting it wouldn't be a big deal. I I don't think that's the
case. Um there might be like if the cops came, they might say,
"We want your computer." They might do that, right? Discord has
the original file. Yes, but like you don't I don't think you
scrub metadata just by sending the file either, right? Like when
you transfer the file to somebody, it still has the same creation
date.
It It's the original file the day it was made or recorded.
If if the court want this information, right, it would have to
be the the the more intact the file is, the the better it is
as as a as defendant so that they cannot put into question the
validity or whether the file is altered or not. Huh. Uh I think
so. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So I would say for
that, wouldn't it be incumbent on Destiny to not delete
those DMs or to like to like make sure that those are preserved
on the platform? Shouldn't those be preserved on the platform
itself?
Wouldn't you want to like contact Discord and say, "Hey, Discord,
uh, this person, this person has sent me CP." Okay, they sent
me CP. I need I need you to preserve this with the original files
and everything. Uh, no, extreme dad, you can't do that. You can
DM me on Discord if you like. Find my new account via the Discord,
and you can DM me on Discord, but you're not coming on stream
just cuz you have something extremely important you want to say.
>> She sent me was one. I don't even know 100% of her age
was legitimately less than 18 when these were taken. So >> uh,
I'm reporting you to the border authorities right now, Darius.
You're never getting in. You're never getting in. Never. Ever.
Okay. You've been reported already. Nope. No. >> He's not
100% sure if he has child on his computer. He's just 99% sure.
Got it. Two. I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to presc.
Okay. XC is just a goof. It is what it is. We cannot take one
more Indian in this country, Darius. It cannot happen. All right.
I will not allow one more.
I will do anything I can to stop it. >> Okay. I think we're
we're basically done with the video, too. >> Well, I guess
if they've said anything, it would just be Well, they're just
doing age play doesn't mean you're having sex with a minor. >> They're
like, "But bro, did you actually
>> Yeah, that's the ultimate age play, isn't it?" >> Method.
He's method acting. >> All right. Well, listen guys, that's
the video. Thanks for watching. This is a VOD on demand. a video
VOD on demand.
I have turned back on all of the donations. All right, I've turned
all the donations back on. I will run through some of the donations
we got today. All right, let's start with some Reuben Ruben stuff
that didn't get played on stream. See, we had this donation from
Ruben Rubin right here.
>> Reban Ruben donated $3.
Wait, Hassan is
>> Yes, Hassan good sometimes. Reuben Rubin should come
through. Hold on. Are we getting this? Is this coming up on stream?
Oh, hold on. That one hadn't finished yet. I think it should.
It should come up. >> It will just be your payment. >> Here
we go. Here we go. >> Reban Ruben donated $3. Destiny doesn't
know musical people when he sees them. He's so stupid. >> Thank
you very much. Thank you very much, Reuben. Ruben,
there's another dono. $5 dono from Kickbot.
>> Five through the [__] house and laugh. You
[__] I paid 15,000 points for you to do the stupid
laugh. Do the [__] laugh, you [__]
>> There you go. There you go. Thank you for the five.
Appreciate it.
One last donation. >> Just tip $3. Way I cover all this
on my stream. You bet. Oh, and if I ever permal log out of Factorio,
it'll probably be on stream, too. So,
well, thank you for the update. Thank you for the update. All
right. Appreciate it. Uh, we also had Geeky Candy with 10 more
gifted. Guys, if you want to support the stream, you can go ahead
and donate. Couple ways to do that. Exclamation point, donate
in the chat. We'll give you the donation links to Streamlabs.
There is Kickbot. $3 minimum on Streamlabs. $2 minimum on Kickbot.
All right. Kickbot has AITS voices. I think Streamlabs tends
to save your payment info in a better way. All right. If you
want to sub through Kick, you can do that. I love individual
subs. Individual subs on Kick are the best way for you to sub
because it gives me some nice rolling income every month. All
right. If you don't want to individually sub, but you want to
gift subs, you can do that as well. All subs on Kick are 955
split. So 95% of that money goes directly into my bank account.
I love Kick. If you just want to give money, you can do that
through Kick and I really appreciate all the support. Okay, if
and sorry, last but not least, guys, there's also the Patreon.
Don't forget about the Patreon. patreon.com/jlk.
Uh patreon.com/jlk.
There's multiple tiers, multiple tiers of support. There's perks
in the Discord for every tier. All right, perks in the Discord
for every perks in the Discord for every tier. You get soundboards
and the VCs. You get priority access to call-ins. Bunch of stuff
going on in the Discord. I really appreciate all the support,
guys. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. All right. All right. All right. Okay.
Hold on. What is What is watching you back, Lincoln? Oh, Darius
was here in the chat, right? We should have pulled. Wait, can
someone explain to me why Dan paused? AE Dan, you're a How are
you going to let some Kiwi Farms user that's still fantasizing
about selling CP win?
What? What is he? Oh, he's talking about destiny, right? That's
who he's talking about there.
That's the Kiwi Farms user he's talking about. Or not. There
are only three tiers. Two Legs is the only person who's in the
supporter plus tier. That's true. All right. Okay. What are we
on to next? I think we might go to some of this Merc stuff next.
Depending on what's out there. I don't know if we got uh some
other funny Oh, wait. Hold on. I think I was going to go through
some tweets as well. Give me a second. Let's go see. Let's go
see what we got for tweets and [__] here. We probably
got some tweets and [__] around here.
Getting rid of some stuff. Getting rid of some stuff.
Oh, we got the West
Hold on. I sent the west thing to Ryland and I was going to say
grab some time stamps if you want, but I think uh I'm going to
just try to find the 14. We find 14 in the transcript. Is there
the word 14?
14.
14. Cosplay.
Okay, I'm putting it here. I'm going to uh
we'll roll it back here a little bit. We'll roll it back here
a little bit. Just listen to Wes going off. I'm going to use
the bathroom. I'm going to get some water. I'm going to get a
drink. I'll be right back. Guys, please link the West AE video
in chat. No.
>> The show's over, right? >> Whatever the the online
that era of whatever people.
>> The Have you the people around here with like the crazy
lips and the It's gross. >> Yeah. This is gross. I agree.
>> I don't like it. But those are the types of people that
want to see you step out of a expensive car with a Rolex. >> That's
fair. That's fair. But it's not like you have to specialize on
these type of women. You could fly from >> But why would
I? I just don't want to. >> Post Instagram. See what happens.
>> Okay. I'll do that. >> Post a Richard Mill on
your Instagram. See what happens. What do you think? What happens?
>> I think you get you get scouted by a different different
breed of woman. >> What type of woman? >> The type
of women that aren't uh cosplaying as 14-year-olds putting on
braces. Uh the >> No. What? You're talking about the Bella
Deline hunters. >> The fact that they aren't needing
>> Okay. What do we um >> asking me? You got it.
>> No, I'm asking. >> Why is he being such a
>> he drank too much. I'm going to get too >> He
drank a one and a half. >> He's supposed to be His limit
is one per show. You go to the casino after this, by the way.
Will you go to with me? >> No, we can go out to eat, though.
>> That's gay. >> Do you remember that stream that
you and
>> I'm sorry. That is effeminite. That is like not cool
and masculine and pogers. Do you remember that stream where you
and I played blackjack together?
>> Well, I we
did I cut in too soon? Did I cut in way too soon that they'd
already talked about the kids? Not directly. I mean like Desessie
trying to be like, "Oh, I just like college girls or something
who like video games." And Wes is like, "You're describing kids
right now. You're describing kids." Just so you
13630.
Okay. Yes. Yeah. I figured we skipped past it and so he's That's
a reference back. >> They've interviewed some of the people
>> based on timing or got lucky based on >> Let's
go. >> He did it. He [__] like Let me put it
this way. The LA police is not still out there looking for the
killer. >> That's wild.
How long have you lived in this area? like two or three years.
>> Do you like the Miami police? >> Yeah, I guess.
Yeah. >> You had any interactions with them? >> White
people privilege. >> Shout out my black brothers. >> Oh,
yeah. >> What's the next topic? >> Um, what you got?
XQC calls denims
Do you know who either of these people >> Uh, I didn't
listen to you cuz for
>> XQC claims denim. I don't know who Denim >> I'm
not impressed. This person this got banned. This This person
never gets banned. recognize
You know what the yellow spoon is?
>> Yeah. Yeah, he does. >> Why did you both at that?
I think they're going to have the same reaction. The wo reaction.
Hold on. I'm being told there's a new Tom take that we have to
look at. New Tom take real quick. Tom take. Real quick, Tom.
>> Still not been unsealed.
>> Uh, nope.
Like I I've also talked about the fact that when I was younger,
so like all this like obsession with
donated $3.
>> Let's wrap this up. I've humiliated myself for the teenth
time to return to my only skill, carpet cleaning. All while being
registered as a offender. >> Thank you very much for the
three, Destiny. Let's continue with whatever the [__]
Tom's going to be cooking here. I don't really want to know,
but apparently he's going to tell us anyway.
>> Today, for those of you who are younger, you don't know
this, but the the obsession with today is very new. This is very,
very new. And I don't mean new as in like back in the,
you know, 15th century, kings were marrying 12y olds. Like, no.
I mean, like, in the '9s,
it was like very normal for
>> He's actually got Is this the Iggy Aelia
I think this might be the Iggy Aelia take. No. Do you guys Do
you guys remember this? I think this is the I think he's actually
Iggying it.
>> Adults to be with underage people.
There was uh it was very normal to them. >> Oh, wait. Ailia
Bank. Do I mean Ailia Banks? I don't know who these people are.
Is Ailia Banks the white woman? The Australian woman?
Ailia Banks is the white woman, right? That's what I mean. No,
she's the crazy black one. I don't know women. Iggy is the white
woman, but it was the black woman. It was Ailia Banks who said
it, right? I think >> it was very normal to to to like
underage kids. It was very normal for um
for like when I was in middle school. >> What is this?
What is this weird appeal? I
Huh. >> normal for
um
to to like underage kids. It was very normal for uh
for like when I was in middle school. It was very normal to to
to like underage kids. It was very
Why Why would you do this,
bro? Destiny. Destiny literally started raiding food shops over
you, Tom. How in the [__] are you this tied to the
plantation that you started making this
>> I Bro, I don't know.
I'm just going to hit play on this. Let's go back to this V.
There's a world >> Why is he laughing? >> It's a
long story. What is your What about it? >> Uh, I don't
know. She just looks like girl with the yellow spoon to me. >> that's
fair. >> We're both okay. Yeah, this sucks to feel out
of the loop. >> We kind of sort of dated, I think, a little
bit. >> like five years ago, maybe.
>> Wait, maybe you were dating when I met
>> Anyway, continue. >> Why is this so everything
yet? She says the most unhidden [__] that this >> I
don't know if we actually have more time on the clock. Hold on.
I don't know if we have more time on the clock. One second. Or
sorry, I don't know if we I don't know if I need the clock anymore.
It's 30. It's 150.
How much do I usually do? 60 and then 45 + 60 and then 45 + 75.
What do I what >> Oh, we're probably there. We're probably
>> anything else donated, we just go over 8 hours. It's
fine. >> Most unlable person I've ever met in my life,
Jack. Guys, I'm not I'm not I'm not going to leak private conversations
off, okay? But as of this at this party, okay, and this person
is insufferable
Holy [__] >> [__] [__]
now. I don't know. I just felt like calling that. >> Oh,
this. >> No, that's probably off. >> No, that's because
your head is never forget it. We'll do something there. There
was something there. >> Maybe unburned. >> You saw
black and you got upset. >> What? What did you just do?
Where'd you >> There you go. >> Where were you before
this? >> On a website. >> We're talking about what's
her >> Oh, I should uh I should hop in the Discord as well.
Oh, I am in the Discord. Never mind. >> I thought I was
in the Discord. >> No, we were talking about Denims. >> Yeah,
Gail Spin.
>> What is she like? Uh who's that got put on 4chan or
whatever. >> All right, next question. >> Who are
we talking about? Speaking of >> I don't know. Uh, this
is what this is what it feels like to have your life work get
down. This is my moment. I was going to do something. I was going
to help people. >> Teachers, get into um, >> dude,
please bring up your your fight with school security guard protect
students. Ready? It's already done now. >> Just getting
into fight with school >> Okay, keep going. >> Click.
I live rewrited your thing. So now the thing switches to when
you talk. >> Oh, go ahead. >> No, I was just reading
the >> Oh, you guys were talking, so I thought you wanted
to finish. >> This feels like when a teacher was like,
"Hey, would you like to share with the >> No, but I wanted
to We were What were we talking about, Daniel? I don't remember.
You said something. I said something. There was a Okay. Asian
making me horribly uncomfortable. Please play the >> Okay,
let's go,
>> These are Everyone says they're Jeffrey Dmer glasses.
>> No, they're glasses. >> Okay. Well, it I kids,
boys, and then them. I don't care. >> Why you have to kill
them, too? >> Because it's Jeffrey Dmer.
>> He the clown guy. No, >> that's Wayne Gay Junior.
Whatever. >> Jeffrey Dmer was the like good-looking guy
who would gay dudes from bars and then kill them. >> Children
or just guys? >> No, no, but he said children. >> No,
dude. I'm literally explaining jokes to you. This is stupid.
Jeffrey Dmer, gay men. He called me a I said I gay
>> This episode He's joking. He's choking. >> I don't
kill anyone. >> This episode right away. >> This
episode sponsored by Israel. All
>> Uh, that's just funny. I'm sorry. I shouldn't find that
as funny as I do. >> How dare you ban Israel for a year
>> without telling them
>> How dare Israel kids for Wait, hold on. >> In
a video game. Nobody does this. Okay. >> Why are you up
off the gas? Okay, we got a lot of >> This is a very >> got
a lot of stuff going on here. Okay, let's This is
>> This is why Wes is funny because he will bum anything.
Okay, that's why that's why Wes is funny is cuz he's not just
he's not here with an agenda. He's not sides. He'll just bump
anything. Okay, that's that's funny sometimes. >> So sorry.
I'm so sorry. >> What do you want to do next? W choose
>> You should have
>> 24 frames of the guest of the podcast is supposed to
learn about the host.
>> Dan, you know what's crazy? All I know about you is
like you were a off Destiny Orbiter until somehow you worked
is your way onto a podcast and like you're a guy who owns a couple
of complexes. That's all I know about you. >> That's about
as accurate
as I can get. >> You didn't send me anything. There was
no anyone who was waiting to come on the show. They don't send
you. You should change it. Send me something. Let me know what
we're going to talk about. I can I can cook some [__]
up. I can understand where I'm coming from. >> Yeah. Just
drop that on the floor. >> From what? It's It's water,
you chimp.
It's It's a coaster. This is water. God forbid your carpet is
touched by it. Your Versace fake rug. Moral of the story is do
some effort before you bring a guest on the show. >> You
know, I realize now that we need more buffer people here for
him to go off on when we do this. Like that's why it would work
with Raphael. >> Way better with more people. >> You
mean buffer people? Like so that we can like >> Yeah. Other
>> This was the Aelia Bank sweep. Okay. >> Victims.
West goes off on us. Makes you feel valued. Other victims on
you guys. I like it. I enjoy it. I'm getting off >> I want
to get more off on you. I feel like Dan's getting too much of
the hate.
>> Yeah. This is this is the beat that Tom Foolery is on
right now. Okay. Donald Trump's defense 14-year-old girls was
really only made a social taboo in the 1990s. My grandmother
was born in 1927 and had her first child when she was 12. Teenage
pregnancy only became frowned upon with the rise of Jerry Springer.
And I also can be honest about the fact that I was old enough
to choose, seduce, and decide to grown ass men when I was 15.
This is the beat that Tom Felery is on right now. This is the
Tom Foolery. This is that Tom Fery clip down to a tea. It's like
exactly what he was doing there. It's exactly what he was cooking.
>> Yeah, obviously. >> Is just a good lick.
>> What are your licks? All I have on you is like, >> "Oh,
holy shit." Can we talk about the fact that you are the cringest
gayest?
>> First of all, we don't say gay here. Okay. Gayest in
the sense of like World of War or Call of Duty. Gay in the sense
of not Call of Duty. >> Love gay people. Support all gay
people. >> Meaning in the sense of like I've never seen
a man's DMs that have made me more uncomfortable in my life than
when >> Jesus Christ.
>> Okay. Listen, they like the cat faces. Okay. All right.
Let's go to the next thing here. >> All right. What's next?
>> You are a master at this, my friend. >> Yeah,
you're a master. >> Do you want to learn about Tyler the
Creator's new album? >> Nope. Why the would we want to
talk about that? >> They thought you were a big Tyler the
>> Can we talk about that for real though? >> Tyler
the creator. >> I don't know. >> Let's go back to
it.
>> If you have videos of you seducing uh >> How old
are you? >> Taiish girls. >> I can tell you. Thai
women. How old are >> Enough to get results. >> But
you're old enough to not text women like you're an 18-year-old
horny virgin. >> It works. >> That's what I'm saying
is that maybe you should target other women cuz the type of women
you're targeting where that works on is people that watch streamers.
Yes. Yes. Wes. Yes. Pie women. How old are you? >> Enough
to get results. >> But you're old enough to not text women
like you're an 18-year-old horny >> It works. >> That's
what I'm saying is that maybe you should target other women cuz
the type of women you're targeting where that [__]
works on is >> people that watch streamers. What do you
>> Stop these type of women. >> Yeah. Wait, should
I walk into the professional world and be like, "Hey, I'm looking
for a >> walk into the world be like, "Hey, look at this
Rolex. Hey, look at this $10,000 whatever you have. Look at my
$100,000." >> No, that's so cringe. Why is >> I'd
rather [__] the people that like the cat faces than
the people that want >> the $200,000 watches.
>> Why would I want >> Wes has a good point, right?
Hey, listen. Yeah. the the reason you don't 30-year-olds is because
30-year-olds want to see some semblance of success from you right
now. You you're
dude, everything he's saying is just correct.
It's just obviously correct.
And Wes is saying this to somebody who goes to Thailand,
okay,
regularly. Spends a lot of time in the Orient. All right. For
a specific purpose. >> Some money hunter girl. >> You
guys look like a 17-year-old
>> It's gross. >> Yeah. as opposed to like here I
am in my $300,000 car with my $100,000 watch like >> Of
course it's cringe. But you know >> At least the girls
that like the cat faces don't have like fake lips and fake fake
boobs and fake [__] asses
and fake in your case. >> 90% of the world is doing the
way that you call cringe and you're the >> I don't know
if 90% of the world is doing the way that you call. I'm pretty
sure this is Miami Beach and [__] taken down.
>> Dan is sweeping right now by trying to interrupt Wes
as Wes just goes the off >> checks on Tinder. >> It's
the guy's way to do. >> Yeah. You're like, "Hey, check
out my roller." Look at picture two. >> That's real expensive.
I got those NFT certificates to back it up. >> The more
wealth you use in the pursuit of And that is the natural. >> I
don't want people that are my wealth. >> Okay, but not
only getting your wealth, you're destroying the type of people.
>> Name a single woman that's gotten your wealth. type
of people
that last anything with them. >> The type of people that
are >> shut the [__] you're I know what you're
saying. You're saying this whole take about how I don't want
a girl who wants for my wealth. But no, >> no, no, no.
That's not even what I'm saying. You're >> literally just
saying. No, that was not what I'm saying. >> Okay, go ahead.
>> The type of women that are attracted to wealth are not
the type of No, they're I don't want to say it's just not my
type of person.
>> Because I like the like the nerdy college like attitude
vibe like anime people. Let's just like
like what is he?
Okay, it's up that he's
basically hitting on a bunch of Rose attributes. Okay,
I'm just I'm just saying I'm ju I'm just saying that's already
[__] up like the like the nerdy college like attitude
vibe like anime people. That's just like my world. >> That
make them younger and younger. >> The people that are the
legal lawyer people or whatever. I don't know what the [__]
there. A lot of the Yeah. >> Oh, it's getting that time.
>> I feel like the show's over, right? >> Whatever
the the online that era of whatever people.
>> The Have you The people around here with like the crazy
lips and the It's gross. >> Yeah, this is gross. I agree.
>> I don't like it. But those are the types of people that
want to see you step out of a expensive car with a Rolex. >> That's
fair. That's fair. But it's not like you have to specialize on
these type of women. You could fly from >> But why would
I? I just don't want to buy Instagram. See what happens. >> Okay,
I'll do it. Post a Richard Mill on your Instagram. See what happens.
>> What do you think? What happens?
>> I think you get you get scouted by a different different
breed of cosplaying as 14. >> Yeah. Hold on. Hold on. >> The
type of women that aren't uh cosplaying as 14year-olds putting
on braces. Uh the >> No. What? You're talking about the
Bella Deline hunters. >> The fact that they aren't needing
>> Okay. What do we um
God actually just cooked them completely.
God, Wes just like a [__] laser.
Like a [__] laser just
sighted in and cooked this guy. How did Wes know? Uh, hold on.
I'll tell you how Wes knew. Wes Wes knew a lot about this guy.
>> Traces based on >> No. But do we have any fun
stories to tell Wes? >> What about what?
>> Just about the
>> The general situation. Oh, Abby. That's a good one.
Wait, wait, hold on. I like the way this is going. Let me take
>> You know who Abby is? >> Nope. But I like that
both of you guys got super uncomfortable all of a sudden. >> You
know,
no. No, no, no. That sounds like a rumor. So, next person. No,
no, no. Give me the Give me the mouse thing.
>> You want it? Don't worry. We both
give me the mouse thing.
>> So, how would Wes know this? Well, cuz they both targeted
at the same teenager, I guess.
>> Give me this. >> Can I get a high five? You guys
look like you're Hey, good job.
>> Is that legacy? That was legacy. Yes.
>> Yep. That was legacy that Destiny just kicked out.
>> That was legacy. Legacy has a Israel flag hanging up
in his bedroom. What? Why the does Legacy have an Israel flag
hanging in his bedroom? What?
He's
All right.
At explain. All right. Hey, good job. You did a great job today.
Okay. Thank you. I appreciate you doing a great job. Let's drag
in some uh >> Why are you sub like
>> huh? Okay. Damn. I missed whatever happened. Uh Wes
started mocking Destiny for also having Abby said they were like
Eskimo brothers.
Somebody asked why why would Wes know that Destiny likes young
girls? And I said, well, here's one indication
>> Oh, Abby. That's a good one. >> Wait, hold on.
I like the way this is going. Let me take >> you know who
Abby is? >> Nope. But I liked that both of you guys got
super uncomfortable all of a sudden. >> Oh, you know. Oh,
is he [__] n
that sounds like a rumor? >> So, next person. No, no, no.
Give me the Give me the mouse thing.
>> You want it? Don't worry. We both
give me the mouse thing. I don't even know who you're talking.
Give me this. >> Can I get a high five? >> You guys
look like you're Hey, good job. Like, you did a great job today.
Okay. Thank you. You're doing a great job. Let's drag in some
uh subscribers. Why are you sub? Like >> look at these
guys.
Okay, I just got to do I got to do that one other call in that
a bunch of DJs soyed at West for. Okay, when they pretended they
cared about women. Okay, remember when DJers pretended they cared
about women. Wait, wait, wait. Did we already go by that call?
Was that calling already? Cuz it had to be here that they had
that call in. That girl was walking around outside. It's got
to be here somewhere. Did I skip it? Going through. Oh, there
it was. There it was. There was right there. All right, this
doesn't work. We won't do it. We won't do the strat anymore based
on hottest pay.
>> Okay, please.
>> Okay, hold on. >> Do I have your consent to remember
when they cared? Sorry. Pretended to care performatively virtue
signaled about care about women. You guys remember >> What
the [__] is wrong with you? I'm so sorry. I'm so
sorry. I'm so sorry. >> Never mind. I have a weight limit.
What the
bay? I love fat checks. What's up, baby?
>> Did I hear that right? >> No, no, no. Sorry. There
was a lot of feedback on our end. We were playing an old west
video, but we turned it off now. Um, what's up, >> how
are you, love?
>> It's up that he's so funny. It's so up. Like, I I can
I can objectively identify that this is really poor conduct.
Okay, this is not good. But it is
hilarious. Uh, first off, Destiny, I'm a huge fan. And Dan,
>> why are you doing this? Now I'm more of your What are
you >> Why the [__] did you give me power,
bro? You up big time. >> A huge fan of Dan.
This guy >> next. Yeah. Anyway, that episode was
No wonder why no women are left in DG. Listen, I can identify
that that's [__] up, but Wes is just openly a misogynist.
And I hated the idea that they brought Wes on and then they're
like, "Oh my god, I can't believe Wes acted like this." Oh my
god, I can't believe Wes was just Wes. Can you believe that Wes
was just himself? Can you believe that? Yeah, don't book Wes.
Just don't book Wes.
No. Hold on. Being open about it doesn't make it okay. Being
open about it makes it okay if you're invited on that show with
them knowing full well who you are. Don't book Wes for this show
if you don't want some misogynist comments dropped.
Sorry. Them's the brakes. Them's the brakes. Okay.
All right. All right. All right. What are we doing here?
I'm looking for one meme right now. Specifically, this one,
dude. We're getting After watching that full Destiny stream,
we're getting so much closer. Okay, we're getting there. We're
getting there. We're getting there. It's It's coming. It's coming.
It's coming. It's coming. All right, we're getting close. Okay,
where are we going?
with the West
Done with this. Maybe Destiny's going to go live and address
the Willie Mack video. You guys think? You guys think he's going
to go live? Add dress the Willy Mack video.
I believe in him. I think he could do
Destiny, go live and debate Willy right
You can save this. You can turn this all around. Yeah, we might
have to go to the merc stuff. We might We might just have to
go to the merk stuff. That might be what it is. Tragically
out of Destiny content. You never expected it to happen.
Maybe callins. I mean, I'd do callins if people wanted to call
in.
I'd take callins. Are people looking to call in on this topic
at all? Call Really?
Why? What did Ozel just send? Give me a
Taking a moment to chill right now. Take it a quick moment to
chill. Always relevant. The 35-year-old groomer meme. Yes. Usually
wouldn't date someone under 20. Let's do a butt. Haha. Check
your Discord. For me personally, I can help with your stream.
Yeah, of course. I'll fly you out. Yes. I've always wanted to
visit. Where do you live again? Hey,
This is such an old meme, by the way. This is such an old meme.
Really? He was streaming earlier. He had no cope left. Yeah,
it's not surprising.
I'm telling you, like he just had that disbelief of like I've
watched this guy like make good decisions before, right?
His own heristics on liars.
>> Then how does a fan know if a commentator is lying or
not? fantle.
Well, that's there's a different level. Kasan doesn't do lies
like that. He does a thing that um >> he does a thing that's
way more cringe. Like there there are heristics you can apply
to people like him where it's like, "Oh, he never watches any
of the original material. He never watches or responds directly
to criticisms from people that criticize him." Right. These are
heristics that I think are broadly accepted and applicable. Yeah.
Then how does a fan know if a commentator is lying or not? Fans
who watch Hassan, for example. Well, Whoops. Doubling up. Doubling
up. Okay. Oh, I have this in the wrong order. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Okay, guys. After
scavenger hunt. Okay, after scavenger hunt ended, there were
some afterparties. Some crazy wild afterparties going on. All
right. And hold on. Let me make sure I've got this all correct.
I'm looking at I'm looking at all of my stuff. Okay. And Merc
had a major crash out. Okay. Major crash out. She went crazy.
Went nuts.
She fought with thief. Okay. Another kick streamer named thief.
Why won't you watch Lily vid? Yeah, I know. We I know. I know.
I got a vid of Lily.
What? You guys can keep linking Cope. By the way, I'll keep looking
at Cope throughout the night. We can weave it into our weave
it into our mer coverage. Okay. But if there's nothing else,
Extreme Dad wants to call in for two seconds. Okay. Extreme Dad,
what's up? How's it going? I'm letting you talk for two seconds.
I'll be right back. I need to get water. Oh, wait. He's just
AFK right now. He's one opportunity. Extreme dad. Dad. Okay,
this guy's uh not here.
This guy's gone.
Well, unfortunately, we've lost Extreme Dad, guys. We've lost
him. >> By the way, I'm here. I'm sorry. I was just unmuting
my my mic. >> Okay. No, I just wanted to say um
I just wanted to say that obviously
uh you were right and I was wrong on the Destiny situation
and um I'm an idiot for that. But you know, clearly you saw this
coming a mile away, but you know, I just I wanted to see the
best in people. But clearly, >> I'm going to be real with
you. I did not see him sending CSAM or possibly CSAM to a whole
group chat of people. I did not see that coming a mile away.
Okay, I'm sorry. Even at that point when we made that bet, I
did not see that coming. I did not expect that. I was shocked
at that. Okay, >> I'm predicted that >> on the technicality,
but um I still don't think he's going to go to jail or anything.
But yeah, obviously he >> doesn't have to go to jail. He
just has to get charged with something.
>> No, I know. I don't think that's going to happen either,
but if he does, like I I I will happily pay my uh
$500. But
>> anyway, Dad, I am so glad you came on here to admit
you are a idiot.
>> Yeah, I um I'm an idiot
and uh everything that I said about Destiny was wrong, but
um I just like I just didn't see this coming, I guess, as far
as like it's actually really bad. The situation's like actually
really really bad. >> Yeah, it's really bad. It's actually
like so bad and I was minimizing it in the beginning
um because I didn't think it was that bad, but yeah, I was wrong
and you were right. And that's all I wanted to say.
>> Okay. All right. Um as far as I know, just to put it
back on the record. Okay. >> Uh June 2020. Was it June
2026?
I think I'm That's what it was, right? >> It's July. July
1st. >> July 2026. Okay. All right. Just putting it back.
>> But let's go. Double or nothing. Double or nothing.
$1,000. Nope. >> January 1st. >> Nope. Nope. Nope.
Nope. >> All right. Well, have a good stream.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Yeah. Thank you. I appreciate it. Well, bye.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. We got anything else? Okay. Oh, Izzy's here.
I'll pull Izzy for two seconds. Izzy, what's up? How's it going?
>> Uh, it is going. It's pretty well. Um, so
I'm like obviously I hopped back in the trenches again with um
all of them refused to talk to you by the way. I tried to get
some of them to like
to uh
get in a conversation with you. I said he'll do it offline. He'll
chat or whatever. And yeah, they're not too uh they're not too
keen on it. So uh
But I was uh in another Twitter thread today talking about like
uh the whole thing with his with the ID. Um I thought no I must
be mistaken and I checked with LED on this. Um did at some point
did Rose refuse to show her ID or did Destiny say that Rose refuse
to show her um her her ID to him? >> I don't know. That's
hard to verify at this point. That's quite hard to verify. I
I think there's some there was some contention from the solo
guy that he did. There's some contention from like uh there there's
like a DM there's some DMs and like an email that sort of fit
with some other parts of the story that seem to indicate he did,
but like they can't be verified 100%. So
that can >> Okay, cool.
Okay. Okay, cool. Yeah, cuz I got into it again today >> and
they said I think Destiny has claimed that she showed a college
ID or like a student ID of some kind. Um
>> uh did he claim that or did he say I think she probably
did that maybe? >> I'm not sure. And did say I'm not sure
because again this keep piling up but um
>> yeah I I I think that I think I remember him saying
at some point something about a college ID.
>> he said something about it but I could have sworn it
was something like kind of crazy and like
yeah I just kind of could have I could have sworn it was like
kind of crazy.
>> Well yeah but I just Yeah. Anyways, I just kind of like
I was kind of twiddling that around for a little bit, but I was
like I mean that doesn't really change much of anything because
like obviously whatever ID he got shown even if it was a college
ID, it didn't have her date of birth on it, right? Because then
he would have for sure known she was 17 at the time. And it's
like this the like the argument that I think is starting to formulate
now for I don't know for the contingent of DGR left is like
well he he could reason there's a lot of uh states where the
law is like uh the defense
for having CP or whatever is um you might that you might have
reasonably assumed this person is 18 and that apparently
like college ID sort of seals that and I'm like That doesn't
I don't think that really scans cuz like you have to imagine
>> I think he said something today about maybe she showed
me a college ID but I think he said like maybe and I don't think
he'd made that claim before and there's no reason to leave it
conditional or or even open to interpretation cuz he could just
show those DMs. Right.
>> Right. Yeah. He would be able to like he he hasn't produced
it. And it's like just like think about this like imagine that
exchange you know like like if I were to just if I were to ask
you hey Jtock are you 18 are you 18 and you say I'm in college
I would I would just be like I mean okay that's that's great
but are you 18? And you respond
uh I'm in college. The fact that there's not a direct answer
to that question is kind of really sus. and he's already
has a suspicion about like
um about this girl's about this girl's age. So, I'm like I don't
know these people don't seem to see or like are basically trying
to make it seem like it was it was totally reasonable for him
to like what he had he didn't have that he didn't have some reason
to to to think that she was >> there were a lot of red
flags. There were just factually a lot of red flags that she
wouldn't sell anything on any age verified platforms. Definitely
like a massive red flag.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like it's just like I think it's just
they're trying to obuscate force
>> like an explicit Yeah. >> Yeah. The goal at this
point for them is to obuscate around the idea of like well why
why would you have reason to think that she was underage yada
yada like what what do you what do you mean like how do you how
do you prove that? Um the I guess like the last thing is so all
the proof that we have of like um of like a Discord that he was
sharing this stuff to in order to like find Rose that it's just
that um it's just that email, >> No, I mean it's literally
him admitting it today on stream. >> Did Oh, in the stream.
Okay. Oh, well, >> you literally said on stream we were
trying to find her or some >> Okay. Yeah, I heard that
bit. Um feel like cuz I feel like if he were ever actually pressed
about it about like the idea of a discord that he was sharing
this stuff to he would probably be like what no he would say
like but he would see that as like some sort of narrative that
he would try to twist that as like us making a narrative about
him sharing like see Sam or whatever. Well, so um he shared the
pictures of Rose that he shared to his DG chat in May, late May.
He shared for the first time in a channel made December 3rd,
December 4th. Sorry, December. I believe the channel was made
on December 3rd, right? >> He shared those pictures of
her in >> And then today he just said we were like looking
for something. I need to find the exact quote. Hold on, let me
find it precisely. Um I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking.
Where is this? Can someone find me the time stamp for that from
today? I can't find that. I can't find that time stamp for it
from today, but if somebody can find it real quick, that'd be
cool. I'll link the I'll link the
stream in my in my uh kick chat. You should find that real quick.
I >> know vaguely. Yeah, I know vaguely of what you're
speaking like the um yeah that that you can look at like the
um the link the links in that particular like discord like um
the meta data basically and you can figure out like the date
that they were sent in and the channel they were sent in essentially
and that like the channels m the channels match up. >> Oh
well yeah I think the thing sorry say that again I was just reading
a DM. My bad. Sorry. Sorry. No, I was just saying I I was just
saying like I think I know what you're talking about like that
the that the uh that the metadata from the Discord um links or
whatever uh shows that they were sent in the same channel and
it gives you and you can get a time stamp or like a a date at
least of when they were um >> Yes. when the channel was
created when the I believe when the message was sent.
>> Yeah. Damn. Um,
so I was going to ask what's the percentage chance what's the
percentage chance of this Discord group even like actually being
real that he actually was just sending this this [__]
around? But I feel like at this point it has to be like a I'm
like plus 70% at this point. Plus 75%
think it's >> I think the So here's the two options. Okay,
so it's he almost certainly made the group chat and he was trying
to find her with the group chat. There there's a an email that
can't be verified that says he was they had to remind him to
censor out because it was possible cesam like you have to censor
out some of these images right that's not been verified so it's
not it's possible that >> screenshots of yeah we tried
to do >> are wait are you in the presentation right now
>> hold up >> join the discord presentation >> yeah
yeah one sec yeah I'm looking at it >> I'll show you it
real quick >> oh yeah because I have of yeah we tried to
do identification for some of these videos. Um, and I tried to
find her through her boyfriend as well because I have when she
would record stuff, she literally has um, a lot of these were
done via Skype calls with her boyfriend, which I didn't really
figure at the time, but we tried to find out who the boyfriend
was based on initials and stuff from here, too. But this is not
the 60 GB
CP folder or whatever. So, we tried to find her, right? We tried
to do this. I think it's pretty obvious that he's grabbed this
from the Wii. I think you got to ask Willy Mack for the link
to this because if Destiny linked this
Um that could be really interesting in my opinion. So if this
was if this was copy pasted as a link from that other Discord
chat then that could absolutely show
like pretty much like
if the link is the same if it's got the same channel ID as that
other one. I think it shows that yes, he's been sharing all this
stuff to try to find
>> Yeah. Um, and I feel like everything I maybe I missed
it because like I was listening to your stream and I was listening
to you listen to his stream, but like I didn't really I'd imagine
if it like if if there's people out here saying that he's sharing,
you know, Cam to a bunch of people in a Discord and that were
just like not true, he would probably be pushing back against
that way harder. He would be saying a lot more to like dispute
that. But like all he's doing really at this point is saying
like, "Oh yeah, we were trying to find her." Like I don't I think
that that this group almost seems like this group almost certainly
exists and like he was sharing some [__] in there
that
>> well he was sharing he was sharing at minimum pictures
of this girl um like
not not party but loads of her in there like right and he was
sharing like from these from the Cam videos at least as much
he says that right. Yes. I I had this because we were trying
to find her. >> That's why he says he had that, right?
>> Yeah. [__] Hell. Um.
Okay. Yeah, that was basically all I had. I just uh just wanted
to clarify and all that stuff, but uh yeah. Anyways, uh you have
a good stream, man. >> Uh all right. Thank you. Thanks
for coming on. >> See you. >> Bye. Why is nobody
from the group chat called in? Hard to say, man. Okay.
I think we're just about ready to go onto this uh this Merc stuff,
right? this this massive merk crash out. They're leading their
discords and formatting their PCs.
Oh, maybe. All right. Okay. I'm just looking through
the defense squad channels going off trying to figure out what
the laws are and stuff around this some crazy [__]
right now. Dude, why is Destiny so obsessed with Shell? Even
stalking my YouTube comments. Lol W.
Are are you sure they're not just looking at the comments on
the H3 video and you're like the top one?
Looks like that's like literally the top comment on the H3 video,
right?
Am I crazy? That's like the top comment for her on the H3 video.
She probably saw it was you and posted in the Discord. Insane
to see the guys spamming lawsuits at people, reading a totally
unrelated set of DMs, pretending they were to the to the same
person. I've never I've never contacted the Rose person on IG
at any point in my life, but this guy and his son suckup crew
are just chuckling along as they read off leaked revenge for
me. very high moral standards, I guess, or just desperately trying
to cater to the audience. ZZZ. Now, let me ask you, did Ethan
not reference uh Destiny leaking
DMs with denims for no reason? And did Destiny complain about
that? Did Destiny go, "Oh, I guess you're just going to reference
like leaked revenge denims on your stream. You're disgusting."
No. When Destiny leaks,
that's based and awesome. When other people leaked Destiny, that's
disgusting. That's disgusting. Revenge. Okay. Right. Read off
leaked revenge for me.
This double standard is absurd.
Okay. Anyway, that's all wrapped in. He's like taking a shell
thing and then I apparently he comments on Shell.
So, somebody asked who that is. One of my number one haters in
Jtock/Kelly Cord. Dude,
honestly,
he started the year and Hassanabi was his number one OP.
And we thought we thought he couldn't go lower, okay? And I don't
mean this as any with any disrespect. Shel, okay? Even though
he could, but now Shel is his number one op. Okay, Destiny's
on the level with Shel. He's He's beefing with Shell.
Start off beefing with Assan and now he's beefing with Shelby.
Okay, this is not great. This is less than ideal. He's in the
trenches with Shell Bunner. There's no way that next one I got
to check what the attachment is first. There's no way that next
one is another Shell Bunner comment, is it? Oh, no. That's actually
That's actually just a Kiwi Farms comment that he's posting.
Remember how disgusting it was for Hassan to read a Kiwi Farms
thing on stream?
If I if I read a Kiwi Farms that Destiny linked to to make himself
a victim, am I still doing something bad or how does that work?
If I just click on him
is that okay? I'm kind of helping him whine, right? Shouldn't
he be fine with that? And so the def begins the deflection. He
blocked three of my alts in under a minute of me replying to
him on them. He's seething so hard.
This is a little weird to just be like I I kept replying on my
alts and he kept blocking me. He's mad. He's mad. All right.
Well,
cool. Y'all think he's still going to reach the goal of surpassing
Hassan in in concurrent viewership? I don't think so. I don't
think so. I don't think that's happening. Uh this YouTube video
seems like is this just going to be this whole thing cut up or
is it just Merks VOD? Cuz it looks like it might be the whole
thing cut up like cuts over >> natural predator deserve
go to jail. >> Light back here.
>> Ready? Uh, I got it. It's okay. Uh, let me change.
>> Actually, I don't want to go over there because I want
to go home and go to >> Yo, that was nice. Perfectly planned.
>> It's cut up and scuffed. H. Okay. Who did some constructive
criticism for you? What was it? I actually don't know what it
was.
Was it that I should do a pirate software thing like he does
where he pretends his voice is way lower than it is? Guys, uh,
I think this Jay-Z guy's voice is actually kind of gross and
and I think he could do he'd do way better if he just fixed that
voice up a little bit. It's not It's not like that, is it? Okay,
as long as it's not like that, that would be pretty gay. Observe.
>> Darius is on stream being humiliated by Ice Beside directly.
Right. Directly, he's farming.
>> Pardon me for the penguin in the bottom right's voice.
I think he needs to get on testosterone. He sounds a little bit
too excited.
too excited. Uh yeah, he's uh he's adding some color commentary
here and that's that's kind of for women. I think women feel
emotions and uh you know, other than my baby talking with my
fiance, I don't really do that.
All right, bro.
>> But it is what it is. >> Yes, he's farming it
hard. Doesn't give a about Darius. Farming his relationship drama.
Farming he didn't know about his girlfriend, right?
How in the does he get off on like trying to say Goonar is a
total piece of [__] >> Because he's a nice
guy and he's really sweet and he's >> Wait, Zena, wait
a second. You didn't tell Darius.
>> Wait, Sam, you didn't tell Darius that >> stream.
You handled it quite well, Darius. You handled it quite well.
>> I'm watching Darius. Darius is looking for new allies.
Darius is in goons chat hanging out. What's up? He paints Warhammer
figures. You're fine. I know I'm fine. I know. I know. I'm fine
cuz I could always just switch to doing like a radio voice if
I was really self-conscious about this. I could do the radio
voice like the whole time. And I really don't have to go up an
octave at all. I could just stay down here and keep things silky
smooth the whole time. But I don't do that cuz that's gay. Okay.
I'm not Pirate Software. That's gay. Keep it Kermit. I am going
to keep it Kermit. All right. Should we switch to Murk the next
day? Cuz I think we got some other cool stuff going on. I missed
whatever there was with a knife. Apparently there's some [__]
with a knife. I really got no idea. >> I was I don't know.
I don't know if anybody knows this. I was absolutely blacked
out drunk at somewhere. >> I was completely blacked out.
>> There's portions of the night.
>> I'm also I'm also getting like sent updates from Destiny,
which is just funny. Remember, do you remember a couple hours
ago, guys, when he was like, I'm just done talking about everything
until the case is over.
And then like
how how long is it? We got 1907 PDT and then we go to 2151.
So it's less than 3 hours. Less than 3 hours and he's back to
seething about all of this again in a move that surprises nobody.
Yes.
Oh,
got to get on testosterone after that one. That's a very feminine
sneeze. All right. All right. Let's read it. Let's read it.
Master Egon, the annoying thing is how much these bully tactics
work. Hassan has literally never delved so deep into crazy as
he has now. The only reason he's doing it is because he's probably
feeling an insane amount of pressure at the moment. Uh yeah,
cuz you and Dan were Dude, you and Dan were going nuts on this
guy. Of course. Of course he's going to your level
for the first time ever.
Why wouldn't he?
Why wouldn't he? You just called for him to get
Are we serious? And these Willy Mack Tourette's guy literally
let him get away with it.
100,000%
yes. Plus, Hassan not having a huge impact outside of Twitch
is him.
Bro, wasn't Hassan hanging out with Zoron? Mani. Wasn't he hanging
out with Mani? This dude whines so much. He really is the biggest
victim
in all of this. Okay? You know, he's capable of victimizing himself
anywhere. Oh, I I just found out that I was disseminating like
like CP to a group of people trying to find my my former partner.
Well, I think I'm the biggest victim here. Okay, I'm the biggest
victim and Solo's the biggest piece of [__] and you
guys have to go after Solo. And if you guys don't go after Solo,
that's really [__] up of you. Okay,
we keep getting sent this stuff. It's crazy. What else we got?
What else we got? What else we got?
I'll be honest. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Can't form emotional connections with people. Only a nebulous
chat. Well, I don't think Hold on. It's because he can't form
connections. BB Poison. those people in the chat care about him
and he doesn't have to do anything to support those connections.
He never has to make a sacrifice. He never has to put himself
out. He just gets free dopamine from these people being obsessed
with him, right? That's not a social connection. It's only the
one-way thing. When he develops relationships where they expect
where they expect something back, those fail every time.
They just automatically fail, right?
That's like how he operates. Destiny is a discord queen. He really
is a Discord queen. That is an accurate interpretation of like
how he socializes.
Yes. Yeah. Exactly.
He's not capable of like giving back at all.
There's just so many examples of that of that phenomena happening
because he's a sociopath. I don't even know. Like there's a lot
of overlapping things there. I don't really know exactly what's
going on all the time, but like
he's certainly weird. He's certainly a weirdo. Okay.
What's up, scumbag? Just tuning in? What's up?
That was my perfect moment to become a Destiny Orbiter.
Well, they've certainly re uh relaxing the restrictions. Okay.
Um I'll be real. We saw the thief catch up stuff. We saw some
of the mer crash out. I'm kind of thinking I might take a look
at this counterpoint again. Um how much time we got left on the
stream? Got maybe an hour left, guys. If you like the content,
go ahead, give me a follow on every platform. Follow on Twitch,
follow on Twitter, twitch.tv/jdlk
with an_t twitter.com or x.com/jstlk
with an underscore at the end. Okay,
All right,
follow, join the discord,
get in the Discord community. Okay, that's the big one. Get in
the Discord.
Hop in there. It's awesome. Uh, unless you're Destiny, in which
case it is like your personal hell because not everybody there
worships you. But like other than if you're Destiny, it's like
pretty cool. Pretty chill place to hang out. Most people like
it. All right. Most people are chill. Most people enjoy. Yeah,
that Darius was just joking. Darius is not like that. I'm pretty
sure. I'm I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure. All right. Thoughts
of being the last DJ of the year? Uh, listen. It's uh it is what
it is, okay? I'm sure I won't be the last one. I'm sure
I'm not going to be happy about whoever get like I'm I'm not
going to be in good company with whoever does win it in 2025,
but I'm sure there'll be one for 2025. On that Mr. Metico stream
with Destiny, did he say that everybody has been sent that the
pictures of the 15-year-old spread around? And worse.
Um I think he was saying he just knew that like young girls messaged
all those people and that he probably knew some other people
got messages as young girl like from young girls and then said
he wasn't going to out them. Didn't want to stand on it. So,
Yo, DJ of the year 2025. Maybe. Maybe.
Okay. I wanted to look at this Connor stuff. Let's just see what
do we got. Valor Media Network. I just want I was really hoping
his stream from yesterday got let go. His stream from yesterday.
It did not.
Come on, Connor.
Come on, dude. I guess we got the stuff from today.
I didn't really want to I didn't really want to do this. I know
he talks to Riyle. Oh, there's a doobie dono. A doobie message
there that I just skipped through. I'm looking for when he recreates
his diagram. Okay, let's watch him recreate his diagram.
I was told he recreated a diagram. Am I Was I being lied to?
Did we not get MS paint from Connor today? Oh, we did right at
the beginning. Okay. Okay. Okay. We did get this right off the
bat. Okay. All right. Let's watch this right off the bat. >> Oh.
Uh, and like I I think I have some pretty conservative instincts.
Um, but you might be more conservative to me and I think you
have kids too where uh you might you might be viewing this from
like a parental lens. Um, so if you have feedback, I would love
it. Um, ban lab loon. I don't want to be a community she's in.
Sure. Cases. I just don't care about Destiny's life unless there
are actual criminal or civil charges involved. Everything else
seems way too obsessive. Sure. But he is facing civil charges
and what he did could be a crime if he did it knowingly. Right
now that also means that the people who produced and sold illegal
material also committed pretty serious crimes.
That's just true. Like the like the people who produced that
and and you know rose if she was selling it. That's also a crime.
That's also a crime. They would also get in trouble. That's also
really bad.
probably a reason they don't want to be found to be honest with
you, right? Might be a reason why Rose keeps deleting why that
person like deleted all of their socials and right because if
they're found I think they actually committed a pretty massive
crime.
Uh it depends twisted rope. Some of the things do seem to require
knowledge. I've seen some statutes that have gotten listed that
require knowledge like actual knowledge of their age to make
it a crime. Now, to what point that would be an actual valid
excuse,
uh, I'm I don't know. I have not spent a lot of time looking
into them. I'm just saying there are some statutes where it does
seem to say there does seem to be some case law that points to
like, well, you need to knowingly do it. Can Rose be charged
for selling her own? Absolutely. Yes. If you're a 17-year-old
selling underage of yourself, you can absolutely be charged and
get in a massive amount of trouble. Yes.
Yep. But now with Rose, who knows if Rose was doing that of her
own like free will. If she's like if she had a boyfriend who's
like 25, you might get really concerned about like So, who knows?
Who knows what the situation was? >> Um, yeah, >> but
I don't want to I don't want to minimize that. Like, yeah, it's
it's bad. Like, you you can be held responsible. It is still
a crime. You should not be doing that, right? You can't just
give somebody a pass cuz they're 17,
right? >> He's not without fault.
Hate the sin. Love the sinner. Radical Coders says, "Fun fact,
Lav and I debated Andrew and Ra Rachel on MDD back in the day.
Kind of a banger. Nice.
I would think she's too busy filming hardcore uh corn and mocking
Ice Poseidon. Is she doing hardcore now? I thought she was always
like a LWD LWD nude model."
>> times they are a changing.
>> Yeah. Sacred Snow says, "Bro, you literally had the
chart up saying 13 to 15, 18 plus is a no-go." And Stylo said,
"So you think 18-year-olds can 14y old guys up saying 13 to 15
You literally had the chart up saying that 13 to 15 18 plus is
a no-go. And Styler said, "So you think 18-year-olds can [__]
15y olds. Guy's a moron." >> 18 plus is a no-go. And Stylo
said, "So you think 18-year-old >> Stylo thinks ReZero
season 1 sucked." So Stylo is kind of a [__] That's
fair. That's like a fair assertion. >> 14-year-old guy's
a [__] Well, that's kind of my point. So,
um, yeah, Jay Stocken and her were in here with all slots of
his community was spamming in the chat and bragging about it
from the
What? In where? In Connor's chat. What? Wouldn't this have been
what? What? What? What are they talking about? Jay Stock and
her were in here with all slots of his community was spamming
in the chat and bragging about it from the Discord. Interesting.
uh, yeah, aka bad. Yeah. So, I know at the risk Hi, hi guys.
So, at the risk of um you know, starting off the stream on the
wrong foot, I just want to double check the pictures that I created
and just make sure that I still believe them
and that I don't have criticisms or amendments. So, this one
I I think is just descriptively accurate. Even if you think that
um these people don't deserve to have platforms, that they don't
deserve to make any money or have any energy or have any relevance
in Twitch and YouTube politics, that's probably, you know,
you can have that perspective. Um, however, for me, >> wait,
if you're going disaster relief, don't you have to give stuff
to Hassan? Hasn't Hassan raised a bunch of money for disaster
relief? Uh, >> generating money on Twitch and YouTube
Mofos were saying that claiming the Discord was talking about
food shops when they were talking about computer parts. Chatter's
just be instigating >> This is awesome, but that's not
my end goal. My end goal, realistically, I don't even really
care that much about canvasing events. We'll do them as a result
of trying to have some kind of political impact. But disaster
relief, IRL community events, and IRL community building, those
would be the three things that I would focus on. phone banking.
And this drawing basically just says that if Destiny wasn't engaged
in constant crazy from 2022 that's destroying his reputation
online and if Vosch wasn't uh wanting to be a horse that had
with Japanese teenagers, they could break off 5 to 10% of their
money and energy and channel it into these things and that would
be good for Twitch and YouTube politics. That's basically what
this thing says. I agree with that. um the forgiveness cycle.
This is probably the most important thing that uh I think some
people in DGG won't like >> that you don't uh like you
don't
actually hold this belief at all. Yes, this is the whole point.
>> This is the thing that I think that Steven is not participating
in. I think that DGG and >> by the way, this is my issue
with Hutch as well. This is I just said if Destiny showed contrition,
if he was if he was like upset that he' done these things, if
he showed contrition, if he was apologetic, then I think forgiveness
is possible, right? But the issue is you guys have started on
like, well, we can forgive things. And it's like, bro, let me
hit any of these next couple steps. I need to see some atonement.
I need to see any guilt. I didn't see anything. >> Consequentialists
and Steven and Vos and VG, they don't really believe in sin unless
there's a negative consequence. So, from like a biblical standpoint,
um, let's say like you you envy your neighbor's wife, right?
Coveting your your neighbor's wife is a is a ten commandment
sin. Well, what a VGG DG Vosch Destiny consequentialist would
say, well, not only can you fantasize about your neighbor's wife,
but you can even have with your neighbor's wife as long as the
husband's okay with it. everybody consents. You wear a condom,
there isn't a pregnancy, there isn't herpes, there isn't any
STDs. And as long as everybody's happy at the end of the day
and nobody suffers consequences, that's not even sin. Whereas
for me, I would say that that antisocial behavior is so correlated
with negative consequences, you're ultimately going to suffer
negative consequences. And so normal people once they suffer
normal con or negative consequences and they also engage in bad
behavior they feel >> and they they want to express some
contrition. So then they ask for mercy from the people who should
be able to instantiate some kind of justice against them. Then
they atone for their sins by trying to make some level of justice
and restitution. And then ultimately if they go through this
cycle, you're supposed to as a Christian, not that I'm a literalist
Christian, but a Christian, um you're supposed to extend them
forgiveness or at minimum God is supposed to forgive them even
if you can't. I think my beef with DGG and VGG
and Steven and Bosch is they think that if you avoid the consequences
of bad behavior, then does it really matter? And my answer is
yes,
it still matters. Um, so yeah. So if I could convince Steven
that this is a moral pathway that he needs to go through, um,
I would and I'll try. No promises, though.
>> What have you done to try so far? What have What have
you attempted?
Cuz it seems like nobody slowed this guy down. This guy's just
slowly spiraled down like the most destructive path and nobody
around him has said, "Hey, this needs to stop. What the [__]
are you doing?" Uh, I don't know what you're talking about, Cam.
I don't like people in the discord will send to Destiny. Yeah,
100%. But what I don't know what we're saying
>> and
uh clout relationship.
>> there are people who just like drama and like seeing
somebody react to drama stuff, right? So, people will send stuff
to Destiny and then uh people will watch Destiny's DGlo logs
and when he says something, they'll send it to me. I don't necessarily
like think these people are evil or like it's coordinated or
something. That will just happen. Um, all I was saying that as
a orbiter,
>> there is this constant incentive to interact with a
bigger streamer because every time you interact with a bigger
streamer, you're going to get a chunk of their audience to come
over to your audience or whatever. And then there's the dynamic
of friendship that you have to decide whether or not you want
to maintain. Then there's this constant um there's this constant
temptation I think whenever you're a small creator and you're
in the orbit of a larger creator to backstab or front the larger
creator because you know that if you have an orbit and you know
that if you have a friendship you could probably double or triple
your viewership when you backstab or front the larger creator.
And so it's this constant balance of like well do we have a good
enough relationship and a good Okay.
Where's the where are the backstabs coming from? I don't
like again I've said this a million times.
You know what the backstab was? It was Destiny's conduct towards
the people that he recorded or distributed of non-consensually.
Okay. Like the like it was Destiny's conduct. That is the
The rest of us did not backstab this. God, I hate counterpoints.
Also, thank you. I assume that's Squeeman. I don't I don't know
anybody else who even raids into this channel. So, it's almost
certainly got to be Quimman Qman live with 238 viewers. Thank
you very much. Thank you. Thank you. It's like it's crazy that
we get this cope all the
Hold on. XKCD. What is this? Whenever I learn a new skill, I
concoct an elaborate fantasy scen concoct elaborate fantasy scenarios
where it lets me save the day. What? Where did I get linked
This is Destiny, but Cam instead of Reax.
Oh no, the killer must have
I know regular expressions. Okay, because he is the white hat.
Yes, I get it. I get it. Thank you. Appreciate it. Remember the
sick boy night on Discord when Wolf Gand got caught speaking
from one of the sock puppet accounts? You mean Spinboy? The Yeah,
I remember that. Yeah, there's some funny stuff.
What schizo memes? All right.
>> Good enough friendship to not backstab and not front
our friends. And that's why you see so many people do it. That's
why you see Xanderhall
burning bridges. That's why you see Vosch burning bridges. That's
why you see um Steven sometimes burning bridges. That's why you
see Britney Simon burning bridges. That's why you see and whenever
they do like burning whenever they burn the bridge, they make
it like a massive spectacle. Um, the reason why they do that
is because uh well well they might do it because they genuinely
feel like they should like they should destroy the bridge of
friendship, but there's obviously this incentive in the back
of everybody's mind all the time, right? This is descriptively
true. Whether or not you think like people are morally good or
bad for participating in this dynamic is kind of irrelevant.
Um I think this is descriptively true. And so what I'm saying
is
uh do you think that's what people are doing to Destiny? Yeah.
Yeah. Now, I think that they can genuinely believe what they
believe, right? Like I think that JTO can genuinely believe that
Destiny is a bad guy who's predatory with women and who's manipulative
and mean and sociopathic and this that the other. And so as a
result, um he genuinely does want to burn the bridge of friendship
and then
>> No, I genuinely would not have wanted to do that. I
genuinely just wanted to not have somebody who was going to predate
all my friends. That's like it. That's it, right? Destiny is
the person who did the action that burned the bridge. I'm not
going, "Oh, I'm burning the bridge with you." No, it was burned
when I found out about what he did. That's the It's a huge difference
from the backstab front clout. Um, however, realistically, like
that's all I really do. Uh, Ral Kit now says, "Would you be open
to chatting?" I don't know. Are you going to be a piece of [__]
Um, probably not right now, but maybe in general. I don't know.
Is it like 10 minutes or like an hour?
Um, because if it was like 10 minutes, I think I could jump on
for 10 minutes. But if it was like an hour, I don't know if I
want to talk to you for an hour. All right. This is probably
going to be the most controversial one from yesterday. Um, is
we kind of mapped out the ages. Somebody told me to use like
the >> Has Connor ever been this person?
I feel like, and maybe this is just me, you know, lumping him
in with all conservatives,
I don't know if he's ever been this person, right? There's no
way he's been this person before where he is saying that like
actually here are the differences in
maturity of all the different age groups. Like here's the guy
in my head, he has to be the guy who's like, "No, you're trying
to [__] like minors. your
but now he's obtained overnight via osmosis all of Destiny's
knowledge and debate skills for debating like I how
>> the Tanner >> I'm not even saying you can't believe
whatever this is right I just think it's so out of character
for Connor to go and do this cope
right I think it's insane >> reference or whatever
um Riyle says I can talk for 10 minutes do we have each feather
on Discord.
find or start conversation.
>> I forget if Connor was a a fan of Mr. Girl. Connor has
always been somebody who says it's it's bad to normalize or to
move in that direction.
>> Riy Kitten House,
I don't think I have you. Add me on Discord, I guess. >> Is
this a ri call right now? And >> if you're a piece of I'm
just telling you straight up, if you're a piece of [__]
I'm going to kick you. Okay.
Um because I'm not going to like be like, "Oh, Ste Steven's a
and you love
you're gone." Um if you want to talk about something like actually
have a conceptual conversation on down
um but if you just want to be like Steven's bad and you're bad
for associating with him, I I don't give a we don't need to have
a conversation for that.
You can think that
in your own content.
Um, invite people. How do I Sorry, one second. Just boomer moment.
It's not even a boomer moment. I'm just tired.
Uh, copy. Here is the Discord link. >> Dude, it's so up
that we don't have this from yesterday.
But it is what it is.
>> Connor talks for five hours straight every day. Pump
those numbers up. Well, listen, bro. I'm I'm just saying like
I don't
if people are like, "Hey, you need to defend Steven's honor or
you need to stop defending Steven's honor." I'm not defending
Steven's honor. >> These are comments on on Counterpoint's
latest video. Willie saying Destiny has CPO's computer right
now. Wow. He should turn that over to the police immediately
so whoever produced it and sold it online gets held accountable.
He did and made a video about it right now. I meant Steven, but
I appreciate your So yeah, Steven should should hand that that
CSAM over to the cops immediately. What if he doesn't? I'm going
to not change a thing is Connor's response. What if he doesn't
do that, Connor? Um, well, I'm not going to do anything different.
I'm just going to keep hanging out. Probably going to go do another
podcast with him or something. Oh, then why why would you say
should? Why would you imply that there's like some uh he something
he ought do if there's no difference whether he does it or not?
Why would you call that an? Oh, he should do that. He should
Yeah, he's Yeah, he should do that. It's It's crazy.
I I don't know. How does Connor think this goes?
Like, I don't I actually don't understand how this goes. I don't
get it. I'm sorry. Why does Connor even need Destiny? Just go
make Warhammer videos. Uh I think he wants to be involved in
politics, but
just going to keep watching. >> Um I'm actually saying
that what he did is pretty bad. Um I'm just saying that I'm going
to hate the sin and love the sinner, I guess. Um, but shadow
to bravo if you have any. >> Why?
Why? I can understand that in the context of like family. >> I
can't understand that in the context of people you have like
a debt to in some way. >> Dung devil donated $5. At this
point with the way he lives his principles, I'm pretty sure Connor
would hold down a child for destiny.